So.
Hoffentlich rockelt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Oh, und wir haben sogar Qualitätsoptionen.
Ups.
Krasser Shit.
So.
Live oder nicht live?
Ja, jetzt wieder live.
Sogar mit Qualitätsoptionen.
Guckt mal.
Pogas, Alter.
Pogas.
Nachher noch Black Ops 4.
Ja.
Später.
Später irgendwann.
Vielleicht nochmal Black Ops 4.
Weil ich habe gerade, ich habe mehr oder weniger seit um halb 10 oder so Black Ops gespielt.
Vorher noch ein bisschen Black Ops mit dem EOX zusammen.
Wir haben eine richtig schöne Runde gehabt, wo wir sie alle weggebasht haben.
Besser gesagt, der EOX hat sie weggebasht und ich habe mitgespielt.
Aber jetzt muss ich mich erstmal wieder ein bisschen geistig da von Black Ops erholen.
Deswegen zeige ich euch mal, wie ich das Meme-Tool verbessert habe.
Das ist jetzt richtig sophisticated mittlerweile.
Ich muss nur mal gucken, welchen Port das verwendet.
Kann man eigentlich den Port einstellen?
Und dann will ich heute noch was anderes mit euch machen.
Nämlich, wie habe ich keine Anzeige?
Wie viele Leute zugucken?
Was ist mit Twitch los heute?
So.
Das ist das beste E-Mode.
Gestern dachte ich, die Abo-Box spinnt.
Ja, eigentlich hatte ich das gar nicht vor.
Mich überkam es irgendwie so, als ich Black Ops gespielt habe.
Ich weiß auch nicht, woran das liegt.
Übrigens, Leute, nur für die, die neu da sind.
Ich kann nicht nur 0.3D-en, ich kann sogar 0.4D-en.
Das ist absolut die höchste 0.0-Evolutionsstufe, die es gibt.
Ich glaube, man könnte das bloß noch toppen mit Omega 0.4D.
Dann wäre es, glaube ich, vorbei.
So.
Ähm.
Was soll ich jetzt zeigen?
Genau.
Und zwar, also wir basteln heute noch ein bisschen an dem Tool weiter rum.
Weil es muss ja mal irgendwann noch was halbwegs Blutsbares für alle rauskommen.
Nicht nur, dass es bei mir funktioniert.
Ich habe jetzt eingebaut, dass man nicht mehr die Bildchen hier im Filesystem haben muss,
sondern dass man die in der Datenbank speichern kann.
Was auch ganz praktisch ist, weil Filesystem an sich gerät dann relativ schnell an seine Grenzen,
wenn man ein bisschen mehr machen will.
Und ganz wichtig, was ich jetzt eigentlich hauptsächlich was ich machen will.
Bisher kann das ja noch nicht viel, außer die Windows.
Und ich wollte mal gucken, also wir brauchen nämlich mehrere Text-to-Speech-Sachen.
Es reicht ja nicht, dass dieses Ding quasi Overlay-Bilder anzeigen lassen kann oder sowas.
Das ist nicht genug.
Sondern wir brauchen natürlich auch noch irgendwelchen blöden Text-to-Speech-Kram.
Und wie das mit Windows-Bordmitteln funktioniert, haben wir das letzte Mal gesehen.
Ich kann das jetzt nochmal kurz zeigen.
Aber, ups, das wollte ich nicht starten.
Das habe ich schon gestartet.
Ich wollte eigentlich eine neue Visual Studio-Instanz aufmachen.
Aber wir müssen jetzt versuchen, noch ein paar mehr Text-to-Speech-Stimmen reinzukriegen.
Also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall mal so die richtig krasse Weep-Stimme.
Also so quasi nach dem Motto,
Mon Geist, Mon Geist, oder sowas in der Richtung.
Brauchen wir.
Console-App, ja passt schon.
Ich zeige jetzt nochmal kurz, wie das mit dem eingebauten Text-to-Speech von Windows funktioniert.
Das muss ich mir aber abgucken.
Das muss ich mir aber abgucken aus meinem eigenen Programm.
So, und dann, das Wichtigste ist, wir müssen uns irgendeinen Weep-Text-to-Speech-Service suchen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es gibt.
Also wir müssen allgemein mal gucken, was es für Text-to-Speech-Services gibt.
Also ich, wie gesagt, ich habe es bloß, ich habe bisher Text-to-Speech nur mit den Windows-Bordmitteln gemacht.
So, warte mal, ich muss mal nachgucken, wie ging das hier nochmal.
Also wir machen jetzt nochmal kurz Text-to-Speech-Windows-Bordmittel, genau.
Das war eigentlich mega easy.
Und wie gesagt, wir spielen später noch ein paar Runden Black Ops, aber ich muss jetzt erstmal mich ein bisschen ausruhen.
Und dann Abendessen und dann spielen wir Black Ops so in zwei Stunden oder so.
Discord hat ein gutes Text-to-Speech.
Was, Discord hat Text-to-Speech? Ernsthaft?
Habe ich noch nie verwendet.
So, kluden wir das Ganze mal.
Jawohl.
Perfekt.
So, jetzt machen wir mal TTS, Say oder Speak.
Mups, ich kann ja mal tippen.
Hallo?
Was zum Teufel tippt der denn hier?
Klammer auf...
Warum machst du ein Sternchen, wenn ich Klammer aufmache?
Die Tasten sind bei mir gerade...
Ah, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Weil ich das indische Keyboard habe.
Windows ist der Meinung, das hat er mir beim Sprachpaket installieren als Default eingerichtet.
Englisch plus indisches Keyboard.
So, warum auch immer.
So, wir machen jetzt mal einen Text.
Mit dem Standard Windows Text-to-Speech.
Das hört sich halt scheiße an.
Das will ich nicht verwenden.
Mal gucken, ob man das hört.
MonkaS.
Ah, das ist...
Das ist natürlich nicht...
Das ist nicht sophisticated genug.
Für unsere Sachen.
Aber bevor wir die ganzen Text-to-Speech-Geschichte machen,
sollte ich euch vielleicht mal die neue Memeboard-Version zeigen, oder?
Was ich mir da ausgedacht habe.
Also, ich finde, das hört...
MonkaS.
Das ist halt dumm, oder?
Hört sich richtig dumm an.
Oder hier.
Omegalul.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Guck, der Silbaro hat uns schon den ersten Link für...
Für...
Japanisch-Text-to-Speech gepostet.
Gucken wir gleich mal.
Omegalul.
Aber das muss man...
Also, das Silbaro, das klingt so, als müsste man sich das lizenzieren.
Was blöd ist.
Omegalul.
Ich will ja irgendwas Kostenloses.
So, Omegalul.
Omeg...
Die...
Diese Windows-Text-to-Speech, das klingt so richtig...
Weiß ich nicht, so...
So ohne Emotionen irgendwie.
Kann sich Alexa nehmen.
Wir könnten...
Amazon Polly könnten wir nehmen.
Aber Amazon Polly kostet auch Geld.
Das ist...
Das ist ziemlich dumm.
Wenn Amazon Polly Geld kostet.
Ich zeige euch erstmal die neue Memeboard-Version.
Vorher muss ich auch mal gucken, dass die auf einem anderen Port läuft, wie die alte.
Wie auch immer man das macht.
Wie ändert man den Port in ASP.NET?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Äh, gucken wir mal.
Wie ändert man den Port?
How to specify port?
Bei default ist 5000.
Ja, ich weiß.
Use words.
Okay, ja.
So machen wir das.
Perfekt.
Stack Overflow Driven Programming.
Also wenn ihr irgendwann mal was erreichen wollt, in der Richtung Stack Overflow.
Beste.
Kannst du nicht Omega-Lul anders schreiben?
Ähm, ich weiß nicht.
Muss mal ausprobieren.
Aber ich will das ja gar nicht mit dem Windows.
Ich brauche...
Ich brauche irgend so eine tolle Weep-Text-to-Speech.
So...
Omega-Lul.
Ich kann das nicht nachmachen.
Ich kann keine Weep-Stimmen nachmachen.
Omega-Lul.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung brauche ich.
So, jetzt läuft es zu 5001.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Jetzt muss ich bloß...
Jetzt muss ich bloß an meinem...
Und auch hier sagen...
Dass es auf Port 5001 läuft.
Oh ja.
Ach so. Brauchen wir gar nicht. Sehr schön.
So, also ich zeige euch jetzt mal die neue Memeboard-Variante.
Neue Memeboard-Version.
So, und ich hoffe das mit dem Port hat jetzt funktioniert.
Also es funktioniert noch nicht alles.
Ja.
Aber man sieht schon mal, dass die Oberfläche viel schöner ist.
Und dass eine Datenbank dahinter ist, dass das Ganze gleich viel besser macht.
Eigentlich sollte jetzt ein Browser aufgehen.
Ist es doch.
Da ist es doch.
So, jetzt ist noch nichts drin.
Das ist die neue Oberfläche.
Man erkennt noch nicht allzu viel.
Hier unten sind noch die Bildchen drin.
Und hier oben kann man suchen.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie die alte Oberfläche.
Bloß, dass das jetzt deutlich konsistenter ist, das Ganze.
Man hat einen schönen Theme-Button hier oben in der Ecke.
Und...
Ja, Programming ist outdated.
Jetzt ist Science and...
Nein, nicht Scientology.
Science and Technology angesagt.
So, und jetzt kann man zum Beispiel hier ein Bildchen nehmen.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal hier zum Beispiel...
Keine Ahnung.
EatsPNG.
Wie schön hier das Track and Drop schon funktioniert.
Achtung, Leute.
Passt mal auf.
Ne?
Das kennen wir noch.
Das haben wir im alten auch noch gemacht.
Du ziehst das drüber.
Geht jetzt auf.
Dann lässt du es los.
Bam.
Upload-Dialog.
Upload-Dialog, wo du einstellen kannst, wie das Ding heißen soll.
Irgendeinen Text-to-Speech-Text, falls du einen brauchst.
Du kannst das muten oder unmuten.
Also sprich, falls du Text-to-Speech und Bilder machen willst.
Also, man muss sagen, das sieht schon sehr sophisticated aus.
Ne?
Und...
Also, ne?
Hier habe ich schon mal ein paar Stimmen vorgefertigt, die es halt noch nicht gibt.
Das müssen wir heute machen.
Heute müssen wir passende Text-to-Speech-Anbieter finden dafür.
Kann man muten.
So.
Und dann macht man Upload.
Zack.
Und dann ist es da.
So.
Der Dialog sollte noch zugehen eigentlich.
Und dann hat man hier das Web-Interface.
Und...
Und das Web-Interface funktioniert nicht.
Warum funktioniert das Web-Interface nicht?
Ist ja Vorführeffekt jetzt.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass ich hier nicht auf Port 55 bin.
Sondern auf 5001 gehe.
Sondern auf 5000.
Omega-Lull.
So.
Nochmal starten.
Da war das richtig Vorführeffekt.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum kein Blauser-Fenster mehr aufgeht.
Wahrscheinlich geht das nur mit 5000 oder so.
So.
Eats.
Alter, was?
Teff?
Monkeys.
Ähm...
Ja, also...
Normalerweise...
Also, ich habe es vorhin ausprobiert.
Da hat es noch funktioniert.
Da kam das Overlay jetzt.
Wenn man da drauf klickt.
Ähm...
Ja, warum funktioniert denn das nicht?
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz angucken.
Warum das nicht funktioniert?
Weil das sollte...
Das sollte prinzipiell eigentlich gehen.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Das müssen wir uns mal kurz hier rauskriegen.
So.
Wo ist denn hier das Update?
Bla bla bla.
Das ist...
Wo connectet er sich denn hier nochmal?
Ja, 5001.
Also...
Prinzipiell sollte das funktionieren.
Aber es zeigt kein Overlay an.
Ich bin verwirrt, Leute.
Eigentlich sollte das funktionieren.
Aber das ist jetzt echt typisch Raw für Effekt.
Aber ich meine, vielleicht ist das Konflikt mit dem alten Tool.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Komisch.
Sollte eigentlich damit überhaupt nichts zu tun haben.
Ich mache das alte Tool jetzt mal aus.
Das ist richtig Early Access.
Eher für die Leute, die neu sind, die nicht wissen, warum man sowas braucht.
Es ist einfach so.
Man kann ja im OBS...
...so Overlay-Bildchen einblenden.
Das funktioniert halt.
Das Problem ist, dass man es im OBS nur selbst sieht.
Und wenn man es im...
Schwachsinn.
Dass man es im OBS nicht selbst sieht.
Und ich will die Overlay-Bildchen selbst sehen, ohne dass sie mich beeinflussen.
Man kann durchklicken durch die Overlay-Bildchen.
Und es wird auch hier kein Fokus dadurch weggenommen.
Also sprich, die kann ich quasi während ich irgendwas streame und zeige, dann zack, einblenden.
Ohne dass es das Spiel irgendwie stört.
Ohne dass es mich aus dem Spiel rausreißt.
Also sprich, ohne dass es das Fenster minimiert oder sowas.
Das interagiert eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht.
Mit irgendwas, was da drunter liegt.
Und ich sehe die Bilder selbst.
Das heißt, ich kann sie nicht vergessen auszumachen.
Also Leute, ich bin jetzt gerade ein bisschen verwirrt, warum...
...warum das nicht funktioniert.
Lassen wir uns mal den Pfad anzeigen, ob das vielleicht nicht funktioniert hat.
Wenn das drüber gelegt wird, was sagen dann Anti-Cheats dazu?
Ich vermute mal gar nichts.
Das kann man allerdings nicht sicher sagen.
Äh?
Der Aufruf, der verbindet sich überhaupt nicht.
Ich bin mega verwirrt gerade.
Ich bin echt verwirrt, warum das nicht funktioniert.
Das muss man dann wahrscheinlich danach nochmal in Ruhe angucken, warum das nicht geht.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das überhaupt irgendjemand interessiert, weil...
...man muss ja dazu sagen...
...hier das zum Beispiel.
Seht ihr das?
Ich muss mal in der Vorschau gucken.
Das ist das Shadowplay.
Das ist der Overlay, falls man das sieht.
Sieht man das?
Ja.
Sagt mir mal bitte, ob man das sieht.
Wenn man das sieht, das ist ja im Prinzip genau das gleiche, was die machen.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass die...
...die sind schlechter.
Man kann nicht durchklicken.
Bei mir kann man durchklicken.
Und da sagt ja auch kein Anti-Cheat was dagegen.
Irgendwas ist hier doch im Arsch, oder?
Also irgendwas ist hier voll kaputt.
Ich mach mal...
Ich mach mal das andere...
...das alte Tool aus.
Mach mal hier rückgängig.
Rückgängig auf 5.000 und im Startup auch mal rückgängig.
Nämlich im Startup hier mal rückgängig.
Und dann gucke ich mal, ob es funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie...
Hä?
Okay, ich hab's irgendwie...
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass irgendwie meine Tastatur rumspackt oder so?
Was macht das da?
Der soll das markieren und nicht blau machen.
Das ist sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Vielleicht liegt es auch daran...
Was zum Teufel ist hier los?
Wartet mal, ich muss das mal hier suspenden.
Ja, das ist halt so der richtig geile For-Free-Effekt.
So ein Prozess-Explorer, dass wir mal gucken können, ob ich irgendeinen Scheiß im Hintergrund laufen hab oder so.
Manchmal nichts.
Eigentlich sollte auch, wie gesagt, eigentlich sollte auch ein Browser aufgehen.
Ah.
Okay, wir machen das auf die...
Geht das zu?
Jetzt funktioniert es wahrscheinlich.
Ich mach das im Chrome auf.
Vielleicht hat das ja einen Bug im Firefox oder so.
Ja, das hat einen Bug im Firefox.
Irgendwas funktioniert mit dem Firefox nicht.
Na geil.
Lol.
Also prinzipiell sollte es so aussehen, ne?
Man hat dann ein Web...
Wow.
Man hat dann ein Web-Interface, wo man Windows, Command-Bra, wo man draufklicken kann und kriegt dann Overlays.
Und das kann man natürlich auch vom zweiten Rechner ausmachen und sowas.
Ja, oder man kann es natürlich auch vom...
Mit einem Shortcut machen und sowas in der Richtung.
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal was, was nämlich auch viel schöner ist in der zweiten Version jetzt als in der ersten.
Ne, im Chrome geht's ja, im Firefox geht's nicht.
Eats.
So, ähm, wir ziehen jetzt nochmal ein neues Meme rein, weil dann sieht man das wunderbar.
Also, wir ziehen mal, keine Ahnung, debated PNG.
Zack, track and drop.
Man kann jetzt hier sagen, äh, favorisieren das Ganze, dass es immer vorne steht.
Wie gesagt, Text to Speech oder sonst was vorlesen.
Also, jetzt mache ich mal das.
Jetzt switche ich mal von Dark Theme zu Light Theme und es sieht auch immer noch cool aus.
Ja.
Das ist viel besser als in der ersten Version des Web-Interface.
Es macht richtig was her.
Achso, der Button hier macht übrigens noch nix.
Ah, das kann man jetzt, jeder das verwenden, was er will.
Und was halt cool ist, dass man das rein tracken, droppen kann, uploaden und der speichert das dann.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Ja.
als jeweils 1234 bla bla bla wie auch immer die datei heißt und hat hier eine sq lite datenbank
woraus sich die ganzen informationen von den bildchen drin drin speichert das heißt nämlich
auch das ist super einfach zu kopieren also sprich wenn ich das auf einem rechner eingerichtet habe
da kann ich einfach den ordner nehmen und rüber kopieren zweiten rechner uns funktioniert oder
aber und das müssen wir nämlich auch noch in einem der nächsten streams machen einfach so
ein billig installer das einzige was die stürzt der abstand zwischen den button oben rechts ja
ich las auf geht haben wieder hoch dann kannst du natürlich dann ein pull request recht für
die abstatt die kölner abstand auch verringern ach ja übrigens das css ist jetzt auch viel
ordentlicher guck mal ich wir haben hier machen wir mal kurz wie kommt wie komme ich jetzt in
den solution explorer rein wenn man sich jetzt mal das css anguckt na guck mal das ist viel
ordentlicher leute und da haben wir jetzt so was wie hier nach
ist die navigationsbar und da haben wir irgendwo auch so einen irgendwo wobei ich glaube den habe
ich gar nicht ob es gibt einfach nur normalen button der halt so ist wie den button eben ist
wo man die navigationsleiste an button die button haben keine extra id könnte man machen man könnte
die button den abstand der button oben noch ein bisschen bisschen ändern aber das ist jetzt erst
mal das kleinste problem was war was ich dabei habe und auch kein inlernen
css mehr multi upload fehlt ich weiß gar nicht ob ich multi upload haben will weil man muss ja
immer man möchte ja noch was zu dazu eingeben wenn ich jetzt multi upload mache dann dann hätte ich
jetzt hier quasi wie will man das war da hätte man jetzt hier quasi 14 bilder oder so drin und
dann kannst du nur für ein bild text und beschreibung angeben oder sowas natürlich
ziemlich blöd ist das heißt es bleibt wahrscheinlich erst mal bei einfach bei
einfachen upload man braucht ja auch nicht so viel ich meine da macht man sich 15 bildchen rein und
gut ist so und jetzt probiere ich gerade noch mal ob das ganze nicht vielleicht daran lag dass ich
mit dem falschen browser gemacht habe wir machen das jetzt noch mal auf 5001 und die form machen
wir auch machen wir auch wieder auf 5001 5001 jawohl starten wir das ganze es geht mal wieder
kein browser auf okay 5001
ja das lag der firefox fragt mich nicht kommen wir gucken mal was der firefox
probleme hat warum es um firefox nicht geht ja doch was zu der ganzen geschichte von wegen
anti-cheat man muss ja dazu sagen ja natürlich könnte könnte da irgendwie anti-cheat zeug
drauf anspringen aber dann anti cheat könnte auch auf 999 andere sachen anspringen was es
so gibt na ich meine es hat ja alles irgendwie weiß nicht in overlay sondern halt irgendwie
Was im Hintergrund läuft, was im Hintergrund irgendwas macht
Sei es ein Virenscanner im Hintergrund
Sei es irgendwie was, was ich encode im Hintergrund
Das kann theoretisch auf alles anspringen
Warum sollte das gerade auf was anspringen
Was ein Fenster mit einem Bild anzeigt
Ich meine ein Fenster mit einem Bild anzeigt
Und selbst wenn es darauf anspringt
Da müssen sie ja immer noch irgendwie
Was da dran jetzt quasi
Böse ist
Ist es ja nicht
Also ich würde das komplett bedenkenlos in jedem Game einsetzen
Das ist auch das was ich vorhabe
Und
Wir haben ja auch mal im Stream
Was
Wir haben ja auch mal ein Tool gebastelt
Wo man im Hintergrund Screenshots machen kann
Und dann Texterkennung drauf
Das habe ich für den
Ja das ist kaputt im Firefox
Das habe ich für den MMO gemacht, dass ich mitkriege
Wenn was im Marketplace kommt
Und das ist deutlich näher dran an
Nehmen wir es mal Cheaten
Das hat ja mit Cheaten überhaupt nichts zu tun
Das ist einfach nur eine Hilfe für Streamer
Das ist quasi ein gepimptes Streamjack
Oder sowas, bloß ohne Hardware dran
Und wir können auch so viele Dinge einbauen
Wir können Streamjack Unterstützung machen
Wir können RGB Tastatur Unterstützung machen
Alle möglichen Dinger
So und jetzt müssen wir mal in die
Äh
Speck
Mal gucken was Firefox dagegen hat
Connected
Error
Event is not defined
Okay
Was genau hat Firefox
Das ist ja mal eine absolut nichtssagende Fehlermeldung
Firefox ne
Chrome
Juckt das überhaupt nicht
Event is not defined
Welches Event?
Wahrscheinlich das Event für Klick
Klick Event is not defined
Immer wenn ich da drauf klicke
Klick
Okay wir gucken uns mal das Klick Event gleich an
Hier im Chrome ist überhaupt kein Problem
Funktioniert einfach
Firefox spackt rum
Guck mal man sieht auch im Firefox
Im Firefox prinzipiell funktioniert es ne
Die sind alle an diesen Message Hub connected
Also sprich
Wenn ich im Chrome klicke geht es hier im Firefox auch an
Und auf dem zweiten Rekord ist es auch nicht so
Und das Bild wird angezeigt
Aber im Firefox selbst klicken ist irgendwie kaputt
Also muss es ja irgendwo um das Klick Event gehen
Also gucken wir mal
Hier Klick
Moment ich bin falsch
Da
Klick
Hier das da vielleicht
Hat er damit irgendwelche Schmerzen
Ich mein
Warum sollte er damit Schmerzen haben
Okay der hat damit Schmerzen
Hat er damit Schmerzen dass hier Event drin steht
Wobei ich glaube das ist ja nicht so gut
Wobei das ziemlich behindert ist
Weil ich brauche ja das Event an der Stelle
Du hast mir ein Whisper geschrieben
Ich hab es gesehen ja
Muss ich mir später angucken
Was kannst du aus einem interaktiven Film
Ein interaktives Spiel erstellen
Äh
Hä
Da reicht mein Brain gerade nicht dazu
Ja Vue.js Line 6
Das bringt mir nix
Hallo Mr. Roxas
Das ist doch im Vue Source Code drin
So
Ähm
Wir machen einfach mal das Event an
Event weg
An der Stelle
Wir machen jetzt einfach mal das Event weg
Weil beim mittleren Maustaste funktioniert es ja
Gleicher Effekt
Ähm
Da ändern wir das hier nochmal drinne
Auf
Moment wie hieß das
Ich kann mir immer meine eigenen Methodennamen nicht merken
Toggle
Toggle hieß das
Wo ist es denn
Ja
Machen wir hier mal Event weg
Vielleicht geht es jetzt ja
Eats funktioniert
Aber Firefox
Ist ja eigentlich dachte ich das ist Geschichte
Dass ich quasi so Standard CSS und und in JavaScript Zeug sich zwischen Browser so sehr unterscheidet
Warum kann ich eigentlich im Chrome das Bild anklicken und alles ist gut
Und im Firefox klicke ich übrigens das funktioniert es noch
Aber im Firefox klicke ich das Bild an und er markiert das irgendwie
Was ist das denn
Warum markiert er das Bild wenn ich da drauf klicke
Hä
Weil ihr seht ja auch wenn ich unten hinklicke ist es wieder weg
Das soll mal einer verstehen ja
Gut aber jetzt kümmern wir uns mal ein bisschen um das Text to Speech
Sorry für die nervige Frage aber Black Ops 4 kommt schon
Ach so
Ja
Vielleicht nachher
Wie gesagt ich habe heute den ganzen Tag Black Ops gespielt
Ähm
Muss mal gucken
Gib mal das Event Objekt in der Konsole
Ne es funktioniert doch
Es funktioniert doch
Es ist ja alles gut geht wieder
Das einzige was nicht funktioniert ist
Ähm
Warum er das markiert
Ich weiß es nicht
Ich brauchte das Event eh nicht an der Stelle
Ich dachte nur vielleicht falls ich es brauche übergebe ich es mal
Aber jetzt geht es ja
Weil ich nicht check jetzt warum das ganze markiert wird
Ich habe kein Schimmer warum es selected wird
Black Ops 4 scheint wieder gut zu sein
Ja ich finde es
Also
Heute ging es mir schon mehr auf den Sack als gestern
Style Focus
Focusable sowas gibt es
Ok gucken wir mal
Ja
Was Focus
Ne gibt es nicht
Es gibt Select irgendwas
User Select gibt es
Aber wenn ich User Select auf Falls mache weiß ich nicht ob ich Click Events kriege
Juckt nicht
Oder ist es vielleicht das Bild was da drin ist
Selected wird
Das Image vielleicht
User Select
Äh
Ne auf was muss man es stellen
None None
Ne auf was was ich
CSS Leute ich kriege Anfälle
Das ist so
Hä
Warum selectet er das
Was ist das
Das ist auch nicht die Hintergrundfarbe
Der selectet das wirklich
Keine Ahnung
Max wenn dich Black Ops 4 und Battlefield 5 ankotzen wie wärs da mit World War 3
Oh da bin
Ja stimmt
Da kommt ja demnächst die Alpha
Das wollte ich ja spielen
Das finde ich interessant ja das finde ich wirklich
Spannendes Game
Das könnte wenn das gut gemacht ist könnte das wirklich eine Alternative sein
Für alle die keinen Bock auf
Zweiten Weltkrieg haben in Battlefield
Ähm
Wann ist denn die hier Alpha Release oder Early Access
Wann war denn das
Das ist doch demnächst irgendwie 1-2 Wochen
Oktober 19 Oktober
Genau sehr sehr nice
Jaja das werden wir auf jeden Fall uns angucken
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Aber das ist halt auch wieder so ein umfangreiches Game
Wo man
Alles richtig verkacken kann
Also das Game hat auf jeden Fall Potential
Und ich freu mich das es mal wieder ein Game gibt
Quasi im modernen
Guck mal sogar mit ner Deutschland Map
Mit modernem Setting
Was denn Livestream läuft gerade
Muss ich mir nachher mal angucken
Aber wisst ihr
Mir sagt jetzt
Mir sagt der Hersteller auch nix
Was haben die denn sonst noch
Sonst noch gemacht
Sagt mir alles nix
Painkiller kenn ich noch
Der war auch schon uralt
Das ist von 2003 oder so
Also sprich das ist ja wohl irgendwie
Ein Hersteller der noch nix
Irgendwie
Rausgebracht hat wirklich oder
Get even
Was ist get even sagt mir überhaupt nix
Mixed
Hmm
Ist das irgendein Horror Game oder so
Ich weiß nicht
Also ich bin da skeptisch
Das sieht schon geil aus
Das sieht persönlich auch viel viel besser
Als 2. Weltkrieg
2. Weltkrieg hab ich ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
Aber nun ja
So wie das so ist
Ich bin ja mittlerweile immer misstrauisch
Nice Science and Technology
Ja es gibt kein
Wie hieß es vorher
Creative
Creative gibt es nicht mehr
Es gibt jetzt
Twitch Just Chatting
Oder sowas gibt es jetzt
Wir können die Grills in die Kamera gucken
Mit Ausschnitt
Früher gab es da IRL
Und IRL gibt es jetzt nicht mehr
IRL ist jetzt
Ist jetzt
Just Chatting ist das jetzt
Und Programming und Art ist jetzt
Creative ist jetzt aufgeteilt in Art
Und Science and Technology
Ja so sieht es aus
Max wenn man Witcher 1 anschaut
Hätte man nie mit Witcher 3 gerechnet
Du vergisst das zwischen 1 und 3 noch was gekommen ist
Zwischen 1 und 3
3 kam nämlich Witcher 2
Und Witcher 2 war schon ein super Game
Und Witcher 1 war auch ein richtig gutes Game
Und Witcher 2 war ein absolut Top Game
Und Witcher 3 war nochmal richtig richtig geil
So aber eigentlich wollten wir uns jetzt
Ein bisschen um Text to Speech kümmern
Also Windows Text to Speech
Also Windows Text to Speech ist schon mal easy
Das kriegen wir hin
Ich mach mal das neue Meme Tool wieder zu
Das werde ich noch ein bisschen verfeinern
Und dann lade ich das ganze auch auf Github hoch
Ich denke das ist dann auch mal in der Qualität
Wo man sagen kann
Da können wir mal was
Können wir mal einen Installer draus machen
Und können das auch mal releasen das ganze
So und jetzt machen wir Text to Speech
Jetzt machen wir erstmal das alte Meme Tool an
Das ich ähm Bildchen hab zum einblenden
Gut funktioniert wieder
Ähm
So ja Installer
Installer brauchen wir weil das ist Windows
Das ist leider so
Es ist super schwierig
Für Windows
Ähm
Programme zu basteln die quasi
Alles in einer Datei drinnen haben
Also das du nur eine Excel kriegst
Und das ist gar nicht so einfach
Das was du noch am ehesten machen kannst
Ist halt wenn es irgendein .net Ding ist
Versuchen da alles rein zu linken
Aber da hört es spätestens
Also hört es an vielen Stellen relativ schnell auf
Du könntest irgendeinen self extracting Zip
Oder sowas machen
Was im Endeffekt auch nur ein Installer ist
Ja der ist dann halt irgendwohin kopiert
Ähm oh User Select für Mozilla
Mozilla User Select None
Das sollte eigentlich nicht mehr
Also diese Vendor Prefix das sollte man eigentlich nicht mehr brauchen
Aber das probieren wir
Probieren wir später aus
Ähm
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen
Voll vergessen
Confused
Ob ich das jetzt wieder auf dem zweiten Rechner
Ankriege
Ja funktioniert
So was habe ich jetzt überlesen hier ähm
Japanische Stimme
Das muss man lizenzieren
Lizenzieren ist doof
Mit Installer meine ich übrigens
Keinen äh mit Assistent
Sondern sowas was eigentlich das Ding einfach nur
Irgendwohin entpackt und ab und zu halt auch mal anzeigt
Wenn es ein Update gibt
Also da gibt es nämlich für .net Programme
Was ganz praktisches
Nämlich ähm
Heißt das glaube ich
Was da
Das ist eigentlich total einfach
Da klickst du das Programm an
Sagst einmal starten und es ist installiert
Und ähm hat auch eine Benachrichtigung
Für Updates und sowas
Ok also der Sibaro hat uns was geschickt
Für
Ach tatsächlich geht das nur mit mit mit
Prefix ok
Der Sibaro hat uns irgendwas für Weep Stimme geschickt
Gucken wir mal
Müssten wir aber gleich mal sagen ob es laut genug ist
Weil wenn wir jetzt schon Text to Speech ausprobieren müssen wir halt auch
Gucken
Also was haben wir denn hier
Japanese
Was soll ich für eine Sprecherin auswählen
Haruka
Ok und dann sagen wir jetzt mal
Omega lol
Hehehe
Das müssen wir glaube ich anders schreiben
Wobei ich glaube Wörter mit L U L
Drinnen ist für ähm
Ist für Japaner nix
Hehehe
Warum
Programmierst du mit C Sharp
Weil es mir gefällt
Oder willst du
Oder willst du darauf raus was
Was für mich die Vorteile dabei sind
Das kann ich dir erzählen
Ansonsten einfach weil es mir
Weil es meine Lieblingssprache ist
Probier mal einen englischen Text
G baited
Overrated
Outdated
Now we G baited
Ihr müsst mal sagen ob es laut genug ist
Hehehe
Das tut ja weh
Was soll ich ausprobieren
Omega R
Hört man das überhaupt
Ist es laut genug
Ah ich habe eine Idee
Vielleicht O M E G A
Vielleicht so
Wat
Ein bisschen lauter
Ok
O M E G A L U L
Hehehe
Das funktioniert nicht
Das ist schlecht
Hehehe
Ok
O M E G A L U L
Nein das funktioniert nicht
Das hört sich total beknackt an
Ok google mal eine Runde
Japanese
Text to Speech
Was gibt es denn da alles
Ey mir fällt gerade auf
Da müssen wir aufpassen
Wenn man nach sowas sucht
Man weiß nie auf welchen Seite man rauskommt
Wenn man da jetzt drauf klickt
Vielleicht komme ich gleich mal auf Overwatch Porn oder sowas raus
Man weiß das nie wenn man nach sowas sucht
Achso ja genau ich wollte noch was zu
Warum ich C Sharp verwende
Also ich muss sagen an sich
Also hauptsächlich
Grund natürlich weil es die Sprache ist die mir am besten gefällt
Aber der Vorteil von C Sharp
Finde ich ist eindeutig dass die
Die Werkzeuge drum herum fallen
Wenn man das für Windows entwickelt
Und wir entwickeln das ja für in dem Fall für
Eigentlich
Wobei noch nicht mal Windows Only
Theoretisch läuft das auch überall anders
Wenn man halt eine ordentliche Oberfläche machen würde
Aber nachdem wir eh Windows Only programmieren
Kann man halt auch die Vorteile davon nutzen
Nämlich das unter Windows
Die ganze .NET Geschichte halt super
Tools hat sowas wie Visual Studio
Oder
Alle möglichen Sachen die es drum herum gibt
Das macht es einfach angenehm damit was zu entwickeln
Außerdem ist viel eingebaut schon
Und es ist halt relativ einfach
Damit auch kompliziertere Sachen hinzukriegen
Und ich finde auch wenn man
Wenn man Windows Sachen machen will sowohl Web Anwendungen
Als auch Desktop Anwendungen oder Konsolen Anwendungen
Oder sowas und jetzt mit
.NET Core ja auch für
Andere Betriebssysteme leider noch kein
Ohne GUI ja vielleicht kommt das ja noch irgendwann mal
Finde ich ist das aktuell
So mit eines der besten Sachen
Zum einsteigen
Ja da kann man sich
Was heißt ich wollte gerade sagen
Man kann sich da drüber streiten
Eigentlich kann man sich da gar nicht drüber streiten
Das sind halt nur Nachteile
Ich finde es zum Beispiel deutlich angenehmer in C Sharp
Was zu machen als in C++
Wenn es aber letztendlich
Auf irgendwelche Low Level Geschichten ankommt
Ja oder wenn du halt
Irgendwas wie Qt verwenden willst
Was es nur für C++ gescheit gibt
Dann spricht ja auch nichts dagegen
Was in C++ zu machen
Der Sibaro schickt mir
Schickt mir Sachen
Kann ich das aufmachen ohne das da irgendwas passiert
Wir brauchen halt ne
Try it for free wir brauchen ne Seite in der Geschichte
Die halt ne gescheite API hat
Alles andere bringt nix
Wir suchen uns mal weiter
Japanese text to speech
Was gibts denn da alles
Ich hab ja vor ner Weile schon mal gesucht
Und ich hatte ne Seite die war gar nicht so schlecht
Die war zwar komplett in Japanisch
Aber ich hab
Es gab ne API die wir verwenden konnten
Und die Sprecherinnen und Sprecher klangen auch gut
Ich weiß bloß nicht mehr wie das ganze hieß
Wie hieß das denn
Wie hieß der Krams denn
Vielleicht hab ich das irgendwo
Aufgeschrieben hab
Ich guck mal in meinen
Notes ob ich das irgendwo aufgeschrieben hab
TTS
Meme Board
TTS Voice Text
Voice Text
Hieß das
Ah ja das da
Genau
Man versteht leider nix
Das ist so ein bisschen das Problem dabei
Aber es sieht schon mal richtig
Nach der richtigen Seite aus
Wenn man schöne
Eine schöne Weeb
Text to Speech Engine sucht
Dann sieht das schon mal richtig gut aus
So wie nehmen wir denn mal
Wen wollen wir haben
Risa, Erika, Hikari
Sayaka
Haruka, Misaki
Haruka nehmen wir jetzt mal
O, E, G, A
L
U, S
Und die haben auch
Ne API
Das Problem dabei wird jetzt
Das wird witzig
Das kann ich euch jetzt schon sagen
Das Problem ist die API
Da müssen wir uns anmelden für
Und die Seite ist komplett in Japanisch
Das heißt wir müssen uns jetzt irgendwie versuchen
Den API Key auf Japanisch zu generieren
Gleich wenn das funktioniert
Was programmierst du denn da
Wir basteln ein Overlay Programm
Also womit man sich
Meme Bildchen im Prinzip
Anzeigen lassen kann
Ohne aber dass man
Dass die Einfluss haben auf das andere Programm
Kann ich durchklicken und sowas
Das kann ich als Overlay wenn ich streame
Oder für YouTube Videos oder sowas verwenden
Einfach einblenden zwischendurch
Ok
Mikro oder was auch immer das heißt
Keine Ahnung
Ich will ja nichts übersetzen
Ich will ja Text to Speech haben
Das ist ja gerade der Witz daran
Und wieso machst du bei YouTube nicht mehr so viele Videos
Ich mach auf
Omegalul
Das war übrigens
Nicht die Stimme von
Haruka
Weil mir YouTube als Plattform ziemlich auf den Keks geht
Und einfach weil mir auch die Games gefehlt haben
Die mir Spaß gemacht haben
So mal gucken wie sich das hier anhört
Ok
Das hört sich schon mal besser an
Aber das mit dem Lull haben sie nicht so ganz
Das mit dem
Lull funktioniert nicht
Das ist einfach nichts für
Was heißt das hier alles
Ich hab keine Ahnung
Ok wir versuchen uns jetzt mal eine
AP Key zu generieren auf Japanisch
Wie gut kennst du dich mit C Sharp aus
Ich würde sagen ganz gut
Also ich hab damit schon einige Dinger gemacht
Und
Habe im Stream mit ein paar Sachen rumgespielt schon
Aber da sieht man es eigentlich
Dass ich zumindest
Was das Framework angeht
Wenn ich durchblicke
Halt bei neuen Sachen
Wo ich letztens hier mit ASP angefangen habe
Natürlich muss man sich da ein bisschen einarbeiten
Aber nach einer Weile geht es dann wieder
Hat Chrome nicht ein Translate integriert
Ja das bringt mir ja nichts
Das bringt mir nichts
Ich will ja das man
Sag mal ruckelt das
Oder gehört das zu dieser komischen Musik dabei
Da fuck
Was zum Teufel geht mir meine Browser ab
Ich glaube das liegt dann jetzt im Stream
Ähm Chillstep Radio
Geht doch
Keine Ahnung
Das Stream von denen ist gerade irgendwie abgespackt
Ok jetzt
Mal gucken ob das mit R U R
Aber das geht glaube ich auch nicht
Nein das klappt nicht
Aber wir müssen uns jetzt mal eine
AP Key generieren
Für diese komische japanische Text to Speech Seite
Das ist dumm
Aber ich meine
Letztendlich kann sich ja jeder selbst aussuchen
Was der sagt
Man kann ja den Text eintragen
Kann sich ja jeder selbst überlegen
Was er da für einen Text reinschreibt
Ich meine das mit Omega 0 war jetzt ja eigentlich nur ein Test
Zum ausprobieren
So
So wie kann man uns auf der Seite jetzt irgendwelche
AP Keys generieren
Das wird schlimm
Wir machen das mal von unserer Linux4M aus
Wer weiß auf welchen japanischen Seiten
Ich da rumsausen muss
Das ist mir lieber
Das ist mir lieber das aus Linux auszumachen
So aber wie ist das Ding
Voice Text AP
So
Wenn man das jetzt so richtig schreibt
Findet man es auch
Voice Text AP
Also übrigens falls ich etwas vergessen habe zu verantworten
Ihr könnt es da nochmal reinschreiben
Rechtsklick übersetzen
Ja aber das bringt mir doch nichts
Ich will doch in meinem Programm einen Text to Speech drinnen haben
Das heißt ich brauche irgendeinen Service der für mich Text to Speech macht
Am besten fällt dann irgendeine Waff
Oder so was hinten raus
Oder so etwas
Was ich mir speichern kann und immer abspielen
Wenn der User auf den Knopf drückt
Also ich zeige euch das jetzt mal
Was man auch versteht
Wenn wir hier das Web Interface haben
Das ist übrigens noch das alte Tool
Gehen wir auf das Web Interface
Dann haben wir hier zum Beispiel
Einen Knopf für Text to Speech
Dann klickt man drauf
Und dann sagt er Omega Lull
Ich will aber dass er nicht Omega Lull sagt
und
halt auch nicht nur mit der Windows
Default Stimme, deswegen brauchen
wir, wir brauchen halt verschiedene Stimmen
dafür, ich hätte einmal gerne so eine
richtig schöne Anime Weep Stimme
dann am besten noch irgendeine russische Stimme
oder sowas, oder irgendwas in der
Richtung, irgendwas markantes halt
dass du auch ein paar lustige Effekte
machen kannst
weil Windows Standard
Stimme klingt einfach dumm
ach er meint, dass ich die Seite übersetzen soll
oh das ist Big Brain
achso kann man
das so machen, was? Rechtsklick Translate
tatsächlich, siehst du mal
wie ich keine Ahnung davon eigentlich hab
dass das überhaupt funktioniert
okay, ist gar nicht mal so schlecht
Translate to English
Name, Mail Address
Phone Number, ja ganz bestimmt
Company Department, ja wir machen
okay wir brauchen eine Fake
E-Mail Adresse
was gibt's da
Schönes?
WegwerfEmail.de, das
klingt auch gut
oder Biom.de
TemprEmail
öh
die Seite sieht aus wie von 1995
TenMinuteMail
Moin, Jora, out
SpamWC
was es da alles gibt
TenMinuteMail klingt gut
ich probier jetzt einfach mal was durch
es könnte auch sein, dass die Anbieter geblockt haben oder so
Okay, TenMinuteMail geht schon mal irgendwie nicht auf
Irgendjemand hat am Anfang gefragt, was ist das?
Was es für ein Desktop ist?
Ist derjenige noch da?
Wollte wissen, was es für eine E3-Version ist oder sowas, ne?
Ist derjenige noch am Start?
Weil dann kann ich es ein bisschen zeigen gleich noch
Okay, TenMinuteMail ist
Die braucht wahrscheinlich 10 Minutes bis sie aufgeht oder so
Also was hat eben noch einer gesagt?
SpamWC
Das hat schon mal ein guter Name, muss ich sagen
Ups
Moin, Sgt. Neo
SpamWC.de
Wegwerf-E-Mail
Oh ja, das ist gut, das brauchen wir jetzt
Äh
Uh
Okay
Ähm
One-Time-Mail-Address
Et...
Et was?
Was zum...
Was?
Okay
Lull
Perfekt
Ähm
Äh
Admin
Lull in 2k18
Mama
Auto-Vervollständigung beste
Ähm
Was...
Was machen wir das da für eine...
Weeb TTS
Was...
Was wurde...
Was wurde heute schon alles geschafft?
Ne, ich habe ja jetzt angefangen
Ich habe die...
Äh...
Das neue Interface vom...
Vom...
Vom Meme-Tool 2.0 gezeigt
Ne, ich glaube nicht, dass es Passwörter waren
Ich glaube eher, dass es Usernames waren
Es liegen derzeit keine E-Mails vor
Okay, und wie kann man...
Wie kann man das jetzt...
Refresht man jetzt ein...
Ne
Warte
Wie funktioniert dieses komische Ding?
Ach, muss man jedes Mal auf Send drücken, dass das...
Ah ja, okay
Ähm...
Gut, dann melden wir uns jetzt mal mit...
Was ist denn das eigentlich für eine Adresse?
Sieht so...
Es ist ziemlich random
Aber es ist auch gut, dass es random ist
Dann haben sie es wahrscheinlich nicht geblockt
Okay, Name
Mail
Äh
Wenn ich da jetzt reinklicke
Kommt dann die Auto-Vervollständigung für die Telefonnummer
Nur mal so blöd gefragt
Kann man die Auto-Vervollständigung irgendwie löschen oder so?
Wie löscht man das im Chrome?
Boah, geil
Wie löscht man das?
Clearing, Save Passwords and Form Data
Genau
Okay
Also irgendwo gibt es hier einen Löschen-Knopf
Okay, wenn es in der History Clear drin ist
Passwords, Auto-Fill Form Data
Hosted App, alles weg
All time
Bam
Die Seite war kaputt
Ha!
Auto-Vervollständigung ist weg
Okay
Okay, ich kann jetzt Telefonnummer-Feld klicken
Naja, ich weiß, dass es optional ist
Das war bei Auto-Vervollständigung vom Chrome
Also sprich, wenn ich hier reingeklickt hätte
Und ich mal irgendwo in Form meine echte Telefonnummer eingetragen hätte
Hätte das jetzt hier auch vervollständigt
Das musste nicht unbedingt sein
Äh, Department
Application Purpose
Alles
Android, IOS
Web-Application
Confirm
Vielleicht darf man das nicht...
Vielleicht darf man das nicht mit Übersetzen machen
Ha!
Hat funktioniert
Hat funktioniert, man darf das bloß nicht mit Übersetzen machen
Welche Knöpfe sind was?
Ich klicke da jetzt einfach mal drauf
Perfekt
Gut
Mal gucken, ob ich jetzt einen Key gekriegt habe
Äh
Wie kann ich jetzt die E-Mail anzeigen lassen?
Das kann doch nicht die E-Mail sein, oder?
Ich meine, Japanisch sieht schon mal aus
Aber
Muss ich vielleicht meinen Adblock mal...
Ne
Wie...
The fuck?
Was ist das für eine Kackseite?
Hä?
Ja die Mail stand ja eben unten da
Aber halt als...
Keine Ahnung, wir nehmen jetzt was anderes
Das ist dumm, das funktioniert nicht
Kann doch nicht sein, das ist...
Wie kann man so eine Seite so schwierig zu benutzen machen?
So, next
Neuer Key
Zack
Web
So
Wir nehmen jetzt das hier
Das sieht...
Das sieht so billig aus
Wie von 1995
Das funktioniert bestimmt gut
Äh
Ah
So
Wahrscheinlich Face...
Ah, ich muss bestimmt die...
Die, ähm
Das ist bestimmt, äh
Terms of Service Accepten
Aber es ist so kompliziert
Nice
Da ist es
Anzeigen
Ist das mal eine API-Key?
Seite übersetzen
Übersetzt nicht
Auch gut
Ähm
Okay
Wir machen jetzt Google Translate
Äh, Google Translate
Au, Mann
Das ist ein Akt, oder?
Das ist ein Akt von so einer japanischen Seite
eine API-Key zu kriegen
Japanisch
Und danach gibt's was?
Javarnisch
Ja, Java-nisch
Hat das was mit...
Oh Gott, nein
Dann lieber Japanisch
Bevor's Java-ish ist
Okay, machen wir mal Englisch
Diaô mathematics
ast ast ast ast. Welcome to your api key is. Sehr schön. Wir haben einen api key. Sehr sehr nice. Den
brauchen wir auch. Lass mal irgendwo hin kopieren. Perfekt. Funktioniert. Yeah. Okay. Cool. Jawoll.
So machen wir das. Cool. Bla bla bla bla. Okay, probiert es jetzt. Deswegen machen wir das von
Linux aus sowas. Da ist nämlich das viel einfacher. Okay, wir können jetzt den Speaker
auswählen, den Text. Wir machen jetzt mal einen anderen Text. Wir machen jetzt mal einen Text.
MonkaS. Your api key. Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das einfach funktioniert. Output Testwaffe.
Hat nicht funktioniert. Okay, dann funktioniert das mit your api key doch so nicht. Sondern
wahrscheinlich müssen wir. Komm, wir schreiben den api key jetzt einfach zweimal hin. Wer weiß,
was die Japaner sich dabei gedacht haben. Api key liegt. Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key.
Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key. Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key. Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer
api key. Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key. Ja, ganz ganz super geheimer api key. Ja, das ist geil. Das ist geil.
Ja, das ist geil. Das ist geil. Das ist geil. Hört's euch an? Das ist geil. Beste. Ich muss,
ich muss lauter machen. Das ist gut. Das ist nice. So muss das sein. So, wir machen noch,
wir machen noch ein Leerzeichen dazwischen. Da klingt es nämlich bestimmt noch besser. Jetzt
machen wir mal das öffnen. Machen wir mal hinten dran. Hinten dran. Oh, das ist
gut. Das ist nice. Wir müssen das VLC ein bisschen leiser machen. Das, äh, das übersteuert ein
bisschen. Ich frag mich ja, warum Leute solche APIs umsonst anbieten. Ich vermute mal, weil,
also viele Services, die APIs umsonst haben, entweder das ist halt so komplett open sourcing
oder wenn das ein Service ist, der halt auch, ähm, Pay-APIs hat, dass die es entweder bestrengen
auf so und so viele Aufrufe, was die hier letztendlich auch machen werden. Wenn wir uns
jetzt die japanischen Terms of Services durchlesen wünschen, dann ist das dabei, dass wir uns jetzt
da bestimmt drinnen quasi ab so und so viel aufrufen kosten. Oder aber um Werbung zu machen
für ihre volle API, dass das eben nur ein Teil davon ist. So, perfekt. Ich find das ist übelst nice.
Hörte ich jetzt wahr? Das ist übelst nice. Richtig der weepshit. So. Ups. Rausgetappt.
Okay, was haben wir denn für Optionen? Was gibt's denn da noch? Haben die sowas wie API docks,
api docs, das ist ein cooles Wort. Das ist ein guter Satz. Das ist ein guter Satz. Das ist ein guter Satz.
Api docs, das brauchen wir. Und das Ganze jetzt bitte auf Englisch. Was sind das vorerst?
Text to Speech. Speaker. Speaker list. Okay, wir haben anzubieten. Haruka und Hikari. Dann
haben wir noch... Was zum Teufel? Was? Was? Ein wilder Bär? Alter, die Japaner.
Unter uns Satra. Was zum Teufel? Komm, wir müssen uns den... Wollen wir uns den Bär mal anhören?
Komm, wir hören uns den Bär jetzt mal an.
Oh du Scheiße.
Ups.
Okay, wie hört sich denn... Okay, Hikari haben wir jetzt... Wie hört sich denn Haruka an?
Ich hör da keinen Unterschied. Hört ihr da einen Unterschied? Das war jetzt Haruka und jetzt kommt
noch mal Hikari. Das ist exakt die gleiche Stimme. Santa. Santa. Wollen wir doch mal auch Santa
machen, Leute? Santa... Okay. Okay, das ist besser... Der Bär ist besser. Der Bär is
am Besten. Das hört sich überhaupt nicht nach Santa an, warum ist das Santa?
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht sollten wir... Ich hab noch eine Idee. Vielleicht sollten wir...
Vielleicht sollten wir nach Monca einen Punkt machen, dass es quasi sich besser anhört.
Monca...
Monka-es.
Das ist noch besser, oder?
Okay.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich gerade gesehen habe?
Man kann hier noch ein Emotion-Level eintragen.
Also wahrscheinlich, wie fröhlich sie sich anhören oder sowas bei Monka-es.
Ach nee, ah nee.
Man muss erstmal die Emotion auswählen.
Emotion Happy.
Oh, wir machen Happy.
Wir machen Monka-es mal in Ultra Happy.
Happiness.
Und Emotion-Level.
Emotion-Level.
Vier.
Also wir machen jetzt den Happy, happiest Monka-es, den es irgendwie gibt.
Das ist geil.
Das muss ich unbedingt einbauen.
Das wird der Hit.
Ich sag euch, das wird das angesagteste Twitch-Tool aller Zeiten.
Wenn da sowas drin ist.
Da gehen die Leute drauf ab.
Okay, wir machen das mal mit dem Bär.
Okay.
Moment, wir machen das mit dem Bär noch.
Bär.
Komplett für den Arsch eigentlich.
Okay, wir müssen uns jetzt nochmal den Typ anhören.
Show.
Machen wir uns mal Show an.
Show kann keine Emotions.
Ah, okay.
Emotions können nur...
Takeru.
Ist Takeru ein Kerl?
Okay, Takeru.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Japanische Text-to-Speech.
Da, ne.
Wir bleiben bei Hikari.
Hikari ist am besten.
Hikari, der Beste.
So.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir, wie der Aufruf aussieht.
Jetzt müssen wir diesen Aufruf nochmal in C-Sharp nachbasteln.
Aber die ist toll, oder?
Hikari ist...
Wie ist das anhört?
Moka.
Okay, wir brauchen nochmal irgendwas anderes.
Habt ihr noch eine gute Idee, was wir mal als Text verwenden könnten?
Okay, wir machen die auch nochmal.
Overrated.
Outdated.
Debated.
Mal gucken, wie sich das hier mit anhört.
Pitch 100%.
Das hat ja mit dem Original jetzt aber nichts zu tun, oder?
Ist das dein Linux-Rise, wenn man es so nennen mag?
Das ist i3...
Ach, stimmt.
Ja, irgendjemand wollte vorher wissen, was das ist.
Das ist i3-Gaps mit Datusleiste und so.
Also, wenn du...
Also, wirklich krass gerised ist das jetzt nicht.
Das ist ein Gnome-Terminal mit einem Chrome-Browser hier und mit einem i3 und ein paar Desktops.
Und wechselnden Hintergrundbildern.
Aber ich finde, es sieht ganz nice aus für selbstgemacht.
Was haben die eigentlich...
Okay, man darf...
Guck mal, deswegen, die API ist bestimmt begrenzt, weil...
Also, da gibt es bestimmt eine kostenpflichtige API-Version davon.
Weil die kostenlose API kann bloß maximal 200 Zeichen.
Was reicht für das normale Zeug.
Und die haben auch nur japanische Sprecher, wie es aussieht.
Fertig ist die Sharp-Library.
Die brauchen wir nicht wirklich dafür, aber...
Man, man weiß ja nicht.
Vielleicht kann man noch mehr Sprecher verwenden.
Gucken wir da mal rein, was die für Sprecher zur Auswahl haben.
Speaker.
Ne, haben auch nur die.
Aber für japanischen Text-to-Speech ist das toll.
Das heißt, wenn irgendjemand quasi jetzt im Web-Interface einen Text eingibt und sagt, er will die Weeb-Text-to-Speech-Version haben,
dann wird das hier im Hintergrund einmal ausgeführt.
Die WAV-Datei wird gespeichert.
Und dann einfach abgespielt.
Gibt doch bestimmt bessere kostenlose Voice-Tools.
Ja, wenn du mir eins sagst, dann nehme ich das.
Also vor allem, was halt kostenlos mit einer ordentlichen API...
Ich habe bis jetzt keins gehört.
Wenn du eins kennst, schieß los.
Wenn du die Stimme noch höher haben willst, kannst du auf Pitch 100%...
Oh nee, ich glaube, dann hört es sich irgendwann schon mal richtig beknackt an.
Aber ihr könnt es mal ausprobieren.
Da muss ich aber vorher mal ein bisschen leiser stellen.
Mann, man weiß ja nie.
Oh, Pitch, Pitch, 100...
Ah, nee, Pitch ist schon 100%.
Pitch ist default 100%.
Wir können das auf 200% stellen.
Was zum...
Alter.
Okay, das funktioniert nur mit kurzen Wörtern, die sich für Japanisch eignen.
Wie wäre es mit Google Text-to-Speech?
Ja, kann Google Text-to-Speech denn ordentliche japanische...
Also...
Interessante Stimmen.
Also irgendwas, was Meme-Charakter hat und was sich für Twitch eignet.
Und es ist kostenlos.
Google sperrt mich instant, wenn ich den API-Key Public auf GitHub hochlade.
Wo hingegen es den Japanern wahrscheinlich wurscht ist.
Ich mach nochmal einen Ticken lauter.
Gut.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz.
Wir gucken jetzt mal, wie wir das in C-Sharp reinkriegen, oder?
Oder wollen wir nochmal irgendwas ausprobieren?
Key-Opfu-Skaten, ja, das bringt richtig was.
Emotions.
Emotions, ja.
Okay, machen wir nochmal unseren MonkaS.
Wir machen jetzt Sadness.
Sadness.
Sad MonkaS machen wir jetzt.
Sadness und Anger MonkaS.
Und Pitch.
Den Pitch machen wir da zurück.
Der Pitch ist zu übertrieben.
Oh.
Deprimierender MonkaS.
FeelsBatman.
So, und jetzt haben wir das Ganze jetzt mit verärgerter MonkaS.
Fast auch besser.
Aber ich muss sagen, den Happy MonkaS ist der Beste.
Ja, das ist auch am besten.
Okay, gucken wir mal, wie wir das jetzt rüberkriegen.
Probieren wir uns das Ganze mal.
Nein, das sollst du nicht auskommentieren.
So, ich scroll mal kurz den Chat durch, ob ich irgendwas übersehen habe.
Ob die API ein Rate Limit hat?
Wahrscheinlich.
Also wenn das dann ganz viele Leute verwenden, werden die mich wahrscheinlich blocken oder so.
Dann muss ich halt jeder einen eigenen API-Key generieren, wenn er das verwenden will.
Dann reicht das.
Aber müssen wir mal gucken.
Erstellst du eigentlich manchmal ein UML für eigene Projekte?
Ne.
UML ist der größte Crap aller Zeiten.
Das ist vor allem das Sinnloseste.
Wozu brauchen die UML-Kram?
Das ist komplett overrated einfach nur.
Ich weiß, es gibt Leute, die schwören da drauf, aber ich find's total bescheuert.
Okay.
Was hab ich übersehen?
Oh, nix.
Gut.
Schauen wir mal, wie kriegen wir das jetzt eigentlich hin?
Net Client oder Web Client ist der Kram, glaub ich.
Ja.
Das hab ich noch nicht verwendet, also müssen wir mal gucken.
Wie kriegen wir das jetzt runtergeladen?
Äh, müssen wir mal Stack Overflow mal bemühen.
Download File, how to download, ja, blablabla, Web Client, ach so, Download ist ja easy.
Wobei wir wollen ja nicht Download File haben, sondern wir wollen Request hinschicken mit unseren Optionen und dann die Antwort auslesen.
Gucken wir mal.
Gucken wir uns mal die Doku an.
Man muss ja sagen, die Microsoft-Hilfe-Seiten sind meistens relativ gut.
Auch mit Beispielen und sowas.
Web Client.
Nein, nein, nein, Web Client.
So.
Add Header, blablabla, brauchen wir alles nicht.
Brauchen im Prinzip wahrscheinlich einfach nur Url-Optionen oder so.
Also so hab ich zumindest die Seite von denen verstanden, dass man das einfach an die Url dran hängen kann, ne?
Denk ich mal.
Das macht ein Curl-D, ist ja manchmal ein Url-Parameter, ha?
Natürlich haben sie dafür kein Beispiel drin, ne?
Probieren wir das mal aus, ob man das einfach als Url-Parameter machen kann.
Gucken wir mal.
Zack.
Hallo?
Bitte keine indische Tastatur wieder.
Ähm, User und Passwort müssen wir noch eintragen.
Das müssen wir wahrscheinlich, das ist wahrscheinlich Basic aus oder sowas.
Das probieren wir mal aus.
Also quasi sowas da.
Gucken wir mal, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie der richtige Aufruf davon jetzt ist.
Äh, und dann sagen wir sowas wie hier, Speaker, gleich, darf man überhaupt Gleichheitszeichen in der Url verwenden?
Was, was macht minus, minus D war Curl, macht das ein Body, ist das, macht das einen Post mit einem, im Body oder wie, wie macht's, was macht's da eigentlich standardmäßig?
Mal kurz gucken.
Dass ich überhaupt weiß, wie ich den Kram zusammen baue.
Wie?
Minus D.
Hallo?
Zeig mal die Hilfe, Minus D an.
D.
B.
Minus D.
Alter, was ist das denn wieder für eine Hilfe-Seite?
Was macht minus D?
Es kann halt sein, dass das wieder so kompliziert zu finden ist.
Using minus D.
Minus D ist...
Data, Sense
Ah, oh nee
An die Uhr encode
Ja, wunderbar, doch, das ist kein Ding
Das krieg ich gebacken
Okay, ich muss das ganz normal encoden
Ja, das dürfte eigentlich kein großer Akt sein
Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert
Einfach, ja, ich könnte auch
Wireshark oder irgendwas anschmeißen
Was, Link ist falsch?
Ah, Link ist
Ja, richtig, Link ist falsch
Das ist falsch kopiert, ha
Aber nee, eigentlich
Ja, für mehr Stimme, Sibaro
Das kostet jetzt aber was bei denen, ne
Okay, nee, das funktioniert irgendwie anders
Da muss ich jetzt
Erstmal gucken, wie man das ordentlich macht
Ah, zumindest wollen wir erstmal die Url
Die Url können wir erstmal setzen, wie geht denn das hier
Request
Wie verwendet man
Das Ding überhaupt
Download data
Das klingt gut, Address
So, und dann muss ich da jetzt irgendwas
Okay, das gestaltet sich, glaube ich, komplizierter
Als ich mir das vorgestellt habe
Den Kram runterzuladen
Ich meine, ich will im Endeffekt einfach nur die Waffe speichern
Und dann gucken
Dass ich sie bei mir verwenden kann
Header brauchen wir erstmal nicht
Es sei denn, er stört sich dran
Speaker gleich Wonka S
Wonka Giga
Download String
Okay, das ist nicht schlecht
Url encode
And url decode
Stack overflow driven
So funktioniert das
Ah
Moment, das ist irgendwas fertiges von dem
Wann kommt die da in Xhook
Damit das auch im Fullscreen klappt, das machen wir nicht
Weil das wahrscheinlich Anti-Cheat wirklich triggert
Heißt das Ding wirklich so
Heißt das so
Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
Ups
Tatsächlich, das heißt so
Ach
Geht's wirklich, cool
Tja, was es nicht alles gibt
Okay, Url encode
Also, brauchen wir
Kommen wir uns das ganze mal abgucken
Die Minimalvariante ist ja quasi textgleich
Textgleich Wonka S
Guck mal, ob das so funktioniert
Bin ich echt mal gespannt, was da rauskommt
Das Ding noch nie verwendet
Den ganzen Shit hier mal weg
Hö
Jaja
Ja doch
Das sieht gut aus
Moin, I am Root
Das ist ein guter Name
Wie machen die das hier
Kann man Curl irgendwie sagen, dass der
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Dass der mir den, den
Die Ausgabe
Hinschreiben soll
Irgendwie sowas, sowas in der Richtung
Ah, da sieht man was er schickt
Das ist ganz gut
Da kann ich das nämlich einfach abgucken
Oder auch nicht
Na doch
Basic Auth macht er
Content Time müssen wir setzen
Es ist ein Post
Ok, das muss man ja alles wissen
Also, da bauen wir ein Post da hin
Wann kommen die Streams mit Facecam
Tja, bei einer Million YouTube Abos
Äh
Moin, komme gerade vom Video
Was machst du gerade, fliegt nicht durch
Ich zeig's dir mal
Also, erst mal muss man sagen
Das machen wir schon eine Weile, hier im Stream
Ich bastle ein Tool für Twitch-Streamer
Wo man Bilder als Overlays verwenden kann
Also, wo man sich quasi
overlay bildchen anzeigen lassen kann mit bisschen sinnlos animieren und so
was in der richtung die halt einfach oben drüber sind und man kann
durchklicken und so was also sprich die beeinflussen nichts plus das tool kann
seit neuestem auch text to speech allerdings nur mit dem windows standard
text to speech so hört sich das an und nachdem der windows
text to speech ziemlich dumm ist haben wir gerade versucht ob wir nicht eine
schöne weep variante von diesem text to speech hinkriegen können das ganze hört
sich dann so an und ich versuche gerade irgendwie diese komischen japanischen
text to speech service den sound abzurufen
aber wir müssen den dingen dynamisch text übergeben was der entsprechen soll
und wir brauchen dann als antwort eine waff datei halt mit diesem text zu weep
stimme das wollte ich erstmal gucken wie man das überhaupt ordentlich runter
lädt
das war gerade okay wie setzt man hier content type da muss man wirklich hätte
extra setzen dass einmal das ding überhaupt richtig content type etat ok
tatsächlich wird content das ist ja sehr dieses ding gibt es gibt's gibt's keinen
ordentliche
keine ordentliche http
library für für dort
netz wo man das nicht so nicht so viel von fuß machen muss kann er überhaupt
ein post machen wie macht man damit einen post auto post data in web klein
upload was das ist wir das verwirrt mich dass das ding wie verwendet man das
geschäft warum kann ich nicht sagen klein punkt post macht aber eine uhr hin bloß
ein paar parameter und es funktioniert da ist das kompliziert upload data
wollen nicht wirklich data upload wir wollen eine post machen kennt jemand
ordentliche dort netz http library mit dem man so was das ist ja der wahnsinn
stack overflow treffen sind wir euch wieder ganz schön
tourstech overflown so geht das also okay upload data da muss jetzt die
japanische seite rein und da müssen wir noch basic aus mit dem api machen post
so und data gibt jetzt was plural punkt ok gucken uns mal an hauptsache viele
buzzwords
ja das sieht eigentlich schon mal das lässt sich das sieht ja mal viel schöner
aus als hat auch viele sterne hier guck mal das sieht ja viel angenehmer zu
verwenden aus als dieses http klein der web klein ding da kannst du kannst
sogar aussetzen und sowas aber das ist schön
wir probieren es mal raus zu kriegen wie man das mit dem normalen http klein
machen würde ob ich das irgendwie gebacken krieg so also brauchen wir hier
viel 1 als bauer speaker gleich
hikaru oder so Dank hepto
speaker gleich wie karin das ist das das dass das und tags queria ist es allein
ich ja mal gespannt ob das irgendwie funktioniert
aand Child
anta als okay
Damit kann ich leben.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Basic Auth können wir noch machen.
Aber nicht von Hand, sondern wir probieren es mal, ob das Ding das so unterstützt.
Ups.
Add.
Unauthorized.
Okay, so funktioniert es also schon mal nett.
Also, wie macht man Basic Auth Web Client?
Das Ding ist wirklich komplett Handarbeit.
Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es so kompliziert ist.
Ich muss das allen Ernstes von Hand machen?
Also, ich meine, ich weiß, wie Basic Auth funktioniert.
Das ist irgendwie ein, das ist, das ist, ähm,
Username, Passwort und dann irgendwie als Base64 oder sowas.
So, wieder da.
Ist die Webseite eine ASP.NET plus JavaScript?
Meinst du die vom, vom, vom Tool?
Ja, das ist, ähm, du meinst die hier, ne?
Das ist ASP.NET Core und Vue.js.
Omega.
Noch Kontakt zum Friseur und Kabum.
Zum Kabum schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Also, würde ich mal sagen, so ein Jahr her, dass ich was von ihm gehört habe,
beziehungsweise er was von mir gehört hat.
Äh, mit Fabian öfters, täglich fast.
Ja, zwar nicht, zwar nicht viel, aber, aber den Fabian kenne ich auch schon ewig.
So, wie, okay, wie kriegt man das mit dem Web Client jetzt gebacken?
Das kann es doch nicht sein.
Äh, Basic Auth Web Client.
Does not work.
Es ist schön, dass das Ding Credentials fällt, aber.
Wir probieren das jetzt trotzdem mal so.
Vielleicht funktioniert das ja bei uns.
Hat das Ding überhaupt ein Credentials?
Username?
Äh, ja, Username ist das gleiche wie unser, wie unser API Key.
Was da zwar nirgends wo steht, aber, okay.
API Key, der da, Passwort, der da.
Geht's jetzt?
Meine Fresse, so schwierig kann das doch nicht sein.
Okay, dann machen wir das so.
So, das heißt, wir müssen den ganzen Krempel von selbst anhängen.
Äh, selbst anhängen.
Das ist nicht schön.
So, dann müssen wir das in den Krempel ja noch irgendwie adden.
Kann ich einfach Basic Auth oder so reinschreiben?
Okay, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal mit dem Typ, das angeblich, dass es funktioniert.
Okay, geht's jetzt?
Es geht?
Krass.
Ähm, wo stellt man die Taskleiste so ein?
Was?
Oder meinst du hier meine Linux-VM?
Wie sieht denn so der richtige Header aus?
Einfach so, ha?
Moin, CheesyPro36.
Ja, so funktioniert es.
Okay, und das Byte-Array müsste jetzt unser Waff sein.
Oder?
Ich vermute mal schon.
Also, sagen wir Filestate.
Hopp, ein Pfeil.
Save.
Ne, wie ging das?
Äh, äh.
FileStreamSave
Es gab doch irgendwie
In .NET ein neues Ding für
FileSpeichern
Dass man keinen extra FileStreamer
Braucht
Jaja
Oder, ne der Stream
Hatte nur eine SaveS
Irgendwie so war das
Aber ich bilde mir ein, ich hab letztens gelesen
Dass es
Irgendwie eine neue Funktion gab
Für
SaveByToFile
Ach, ja
Genau
So war das
So, dann ist halt
So und das sollte
Eigentlich jetzt unsere MonkaS
Waffdatei sein
Ich hoffe mal, das kommt
Da jetzt irgendwie hin
Gucken wir mal
Ich hab ja meine Zweifel, ob das funktioniert
Es funktioniert
Ja
Funktioniert
Krass
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es einfach so geht
Ein
Sehr, sehr nicer Download
Okay, nachdem wir jetzt prinzipiell
Wissen, wie das funktioniert, können wir das das nächste Mal
Auch in das Meme-Tool einbauen
Ja, und
Jetzt, wie gesagt, für alle, die jetzt neu dabei sind
Zur Erklärung, was ich eigentlich vorhabe
Wir haben ja hier mein
Ja, das ist die neue Version
Hier dieses Tool für Overlays und sowas
Also das ist eigentlich dafür gedacht
Dass man es auf dem zweiten Rechner verwendet
Na, also
Auf dem gleichen Rechner ist bescheuert
Man kann
Dieses Bildchen kann man
Shortcuts zuweisen
Hier wie zum Beispiel
Steuerung F10
Ist hier Poggers
So, und dann macht man sich auf dem zweiten Rechner
Macht man sich das auf
Und da kann man dann halt Sachen öffnen, die man
Wo man sich halt die Shortcuts nicht merken kann
Zum Beispiel Eats oder sowas
Was halt für Leute, die streamen oder YouTube-Videos machen
Oder so
Halt mit, mit
Wenn du halt irgendwas aufzeichnest
Echt praktisch ist
Wenn du irgendwas anzeigen willst
Dass du es eben selber siehst
Im OBS kannst du nur einstellen, dass es die Leute sehen
Und hier siehst du es halt selbst
Wir haben noch ein OBS-Overlay
Das ist das hier
Das ist quasi
Ah, man sieht es also im Hintergrund
Das ist, wenn man möchte, dass es eben nicht
Hier angezeigt wird selbst
Sondern nur im OBS
Da kann man das ausschalten
Dass man das Bild hier oben anzeigt
Und man hat hier quasi einen extra
Browser-Fenster
Was man quasi im OBS hinzufügen kann
Also jeder wie er will
So und jetzt wollen wir dem Ding natürlich
Nicht nur Bildchen anzeigen lassen können
Sondern auch Text-to-Speech
Und dann natürlich mit schönen
Vielen verschiedenen Voice-Dingern
Ja
Und dafür haben wir jetzt
Eine schöne japanische
Voice-API gefunden
Mit der man das machen kann
So und jetzt müssen wir diese komische
Url-Encode-Geschichte nochmal verwenden
Url-Encode
Das ist jetzt zum Ausprobieren
Das funktioniert so
Speaker gleich, das da, das da
Text
So, mal gucken, ob das jetzt so funktioniert
Encoded
Höh
Was ist da jetzt falsch?
Moment, was war ich jetzt hier verkehrt?
Ach Quatsch, ich will ja gar nicht alles
Url-Encoden
Da habe ich geknackt
Ich will nicht alles Url-Encoden
Ich will eigentlich nur das hier Url-Encoden
Weil es das ist
Was ich mit dem Leerzeichen drinnen brauche
Also machen wir jetzt irgendwie sowas hier
So, ich muss da gleich Pizza essen
Und danach spielen wir noch eine Runde Black Ops
Hast du noch vor
Eine Twitch-Integration zu bauen
Also dass der Chat die Memes triggern kann?
Ja, das habe ich mir alles schon aufgeschrieben
Ich habe eine riesen Liste
Mit was wir noch alles einbauen werden
Das wird sich halt ein bisschen hinziehen, ne?
Wobei, ne, wir können
Es gibt jetzt ja irgendwas neues
Es gab irgendwie neue
String Interpolation gab es doch jetzt
Habe ich
Gesehen
Irgendwie in C-Sharp
6 oder 7
Das ist neu
Weiß ich bloß die Syntax nicht mehr
Ah ja, so, genau
Da braucht man nämlich den ganzen Mist nicht mehr
Und dann
Ah, und dann kann man das einfach einsetzen
Ja, das ist schön
Sehr, sehr nice
Alter, wo ist denn das Problem jetzt?
Ich bin da irgendwie gerade zu unfähig für
Ach, ich muss das nicht
Ich muss den
Ich muss wahrscheinlich nur MonkaS encoden, ne?
Ah
Kannst du mal die neue Version vom Memeboard zeigen?
Ja, mache ich gleich
Okay, nice
Okay, dann weiß ich jetzt wie der Krams funktioniert
Sehr schön
Und jetzt haben wir hier wahrscheinlich unsere
Audio
Audio-Datei
So, und mit einem Punkt, das ist gut
Dazwischen sollte die jetzt eigentlich länger
Brauchen beim aussprechen
Monka
Ah, wunderbar
Ja, die neue Version vom Memeboard zeige ich
Klar
Hallo
Er möge sich beenden
Ja, die neue Version
Die ist deutlich ordentlicher als die alte
Besteht jetzt aus zwei Projekten
Nämlich dem Webfrontend
Und der WPF Anwendung
Die halt das Overlay anzeigt
Und
Wie gesagt, es ist aber halt noch nicht alles drinne
Was in der alten Version drinne ist
Auch das CSS ist deutlich ordentlicher
Ich kanns ja mal zeigen gerade
Das CSS ist deutlich ordentlicher
Das Javascript ist deutlich ordentlicher
Und das HTML ist tatsächlich auch deutlich ordentlicher
Da blick ich auch noch durch
Das heißt wir können das auch besser erweitern irgendwie
Okay, ich zeig mir die neue Version
Zack
5001 müssen wir
Da ist jetzt nicht viel drinne
Außer Eats
Aber was man hier sieht zum Beispiel
Also der große Unterschied
Warum ich es überhaupt gesagt habe
Ich muss das nochmal grundlegend anders verändern
Ist die alte Version
Also sprich die ich hier gerade die ganze Zeit noch offen hatte
Da hast du quasi
Die ganzen Bilder hier im Filesystem liegen gehabt
Inklusive allen Informationen
Für die Bilder
Also sprich du hattest im Dateinamen irgendwie ganz kryptisch
Musstest du reinschreiben
Auch für welchen Shortcut du für das Bild verwenden willst
Und sowas
Was natürlich auch dazu geführt hat
Dass man manche Sachen überhaupt nicht machen konnte
Also sprich wenn ich jetzt irgendwie will
Dass ich noch eine Beschreibung für so ein Bild vergeben kann
Ja
Eine Beschreibung die ich dann hier oben später
Auch durchsuchen kann
Geht das nicht
Weil du hast halt nur den Dateinamen letztendlich
Und den Shortcut irgendwie in den Dateinamen
Rein zu entconen ist natürlich auch nicht
Nicht sonderlich toll
Deswegen habe ich gedacht wir machen da einfach
Eine SQLite Datenbank unten drunter
Wo da Sachen drinnen gespeichert werden
Die Bilder werden im separaten Ordner gespeichert
Weil Bilder in der Datenbank speichern ist meistens
Ich mein bei der Anzahl von Bildern ist es scheiß egal
Aber eigentlich
Muss es nicht unbedingt sein
Sowas ist auf dem Filesystem besser aufgehoben
Und das heißt wenn man jetzt ein neues Bild nimmt
Aber das hast du bewusst gemacht
Mit dem Dateinamen
Ja ja habe ich
Ich wollte das damals möglichst easy haben
Bis mir dann aufgefallen ist
Nachdem ich es dann eine Weile verwendet habe
Das es das eigentlich viel komplizierter macht
Du kannst nämlich
Manche Sachen schlicht und ergreifend nicht machen
Wie beispielsweise eine Beschreibung
Hinterlegen
Für dieses Bildchen
Also ich könnte ja sagen okay
Ich tagge meine Bilder
Für den jeweiligen Anlass
Ich habe Funny Bilder
Ich habe Bible Thumb Bilder
Ich habe was auch immer
Und wenn ich danach suchen will geht das nicht
Weil das kann ich in Dateinamen nicht reinschreiben
Was auch überhaupt nicht funktionieren würde
Ist wenn ich zum Beispiel
Ein Bild plus den Text to Speech
Haben möchte auf einer Sache
Geht nicht
Weil wie soll ich hier den Text to Speech hinterlegen
Wenn ich ja schon nur den Dateinamen habe
Also das funktioniert nicht richtig
Deswegen kann man in der neuen Version
Kann man jetzt sagen okay wir nehmen das Bild
Track und Drop das rein
Dann geht ein Popup auf wo ich sagen kann
Ich will das Ding Name haben
Ich will Text haben
So was weiß ich Happy
Was weiß ich Happy
Irgendwas
Voll Robbe
Was immer irgendwas
Oder das ist toller Text
Irgendwas
Also was weiß ich nicht im Dateinamen
Das kann ich in der Datenbank speichern
Und dann kann ich gleichermaßen noch sagen okay
Ich möchte das dieser Text vorgelesen wird
Also könnte ich zum Beispiel sagen
Po Girls
Dann sage ich jawohl ich will das nicht nur das Bild angezeigt wird
Sondern auch Text vorgelesen wird
Dann mache ich hier den Mute Knopf aus
Suche mir eine schöne Stimme aus
Eine japanische Weep Emote Stimme
Monka es
Und
Also das geht natürlich über den Webservice vorher
Weil ich weiß ja nicht was da für ein Text drin ist
Ja und dann drücke ich Upload
Und dann ist das Ding
Da und das CSS ist komisch formatiert
Dann ist es da
Und das ist deutlich sauberer und schöner
Als noch
In der alten Version
Und nochmal eine Sache was auch ganz cool ist
Man hat jetzt
Ein ordentliches Dark und Light Theme
Das hat man in der alten Version zwar auch schon gehabt
Das ist die alte Version hier
Aber ich fand es ehrlich gesagt
Nicht so schick
Und halt mit den ganzen
Beschränkungen die man auch drinnen hatte
Deswegen kann man jetzt hier sagen zum Beispiel
Light Theme
Sieht immer noch sehr schick aus
Rot ist Rot Grün ist Grün
Aber in jedem Fall zu einem anderen Ton
Und jetzt ist es wieder dunkel
Wobei Dark Theme ist natürlich Default weil es besser aussieht
Wäre cool
Wenn man sich die Stimme anhören kann
Bevor man es auf Hochladen drückt
Jaja das machen wir auch noch
Ich habe mal gedacht wir machen hier noch so einen Brief You Play Button
Dann kann man es sich einmal anhören
Wie es ist
Wobei man es halt immer hochladen kann
Und dann quasi im Nachhinein nochmal editieren
Also sprich
Man kann es im Nachhinein nochmal editieren
Das funktioniert zum Beispiel noch nicht richtig
Wenn ich jetzt hier mittlere Maustaste drücke
Das
Dann hat er hier zwar da stehen
Aber
Er ändert es noch nicht richtig
Ja
Und dann kann ich ja im Nachhinein immer noch umstellen
Das ist ja
Deswegen habe ich es ja auch gerade mit einer SQLite Datenbank im Hintergrund gemacht
Wenn das der Urheberrechtsverletzungssimulator
Das hängt von demjenigen ab
Der es benutzt was er reinzieht
Standardmäßig kommt das ohne Bilder
Wie sollte es auch anders sein
Ich werde mich hüten irgendwelche Bilder standardmäßig mitzuliefern
Vielleicht irgend so ein Pepe Ding
Könnte man standardmäßig mitliefern
Ich weiß nicht wie es da Copyright technisch aussieht
Ja ja
iSnaps genau das soll da auch noch rein
Ja
Also wie gesagt
Das ist noch nicht auf dem Stand
Von der ersten Version alles
Ja ja das soll da rein
Also das können wir ja gerade mal machen
Das soll da auf jeden Fall rein
Also sprich
An der Stelle wo jetzt hier
Hier ist das Upload Popup
Da könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel rein machen
Also hier sagt er bla bla Text to Speech
Da machen wir jetzt noch ein
Da machen wir jetzt noch ein Label
Hotkey
Ja Model haben wir dafür noch nicht
Das müssen wir hier eintragen
Hotkey
Ja ja so ist das gedacht
So und wenn wir das jetzt nochmal reloaden
Und wenn ich mich jetzt nicht verschrieben habe
Dann sollte es da ein Feld für
Hotkey geben
Äh der Label Text stimmt noch nicht
Äh
Placeholder Text
Hotkey
Ja ja so ist das gedacht
So und wenn man dann
Den Hotkey eingetragen hat
Und auf Upload drückt
Also zum Beispiel wir müssen uns mal überlegen
Wie man die Syntax machen
Ob wir sowas hier sagen
Control plus plus G oder irgendwie sowas
Oder ob wir standardmäßig Control nehmen
Und hier nur G eintragen
Mal gucken
Da könnte man ja irgendein Setting draus machen
Was quasi der globale
Ähm
Modifier ist
Also sprich ob es Control ist
Ob es Alt Alt plus Control
Oder Alt Shift oder so
Das kann sich dann derjenige aussuchen das verwendet
Genau aber wie du es geschrieben hast
Eben für Snaps
iSnaps
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ob er es geschrieben hat
Genau iSnaps
So ist das gedacht
Ja ja oder genau wie das hier
Dropdown für Control Alt
Das können wir alles noch machen
Man könnte es sogar Capturen lassen
Dass man sagen
Hier jetzt Taste drücken
Und dann machen wir das
Ja und weil gerade jemand schreibt
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel
Weil gerade jemand schreibt Alt plus F4
Das ist ein typischer Fall von
Shortcut ist schon belegt
Und das ist auch was was wir noch hinkriegen müssen
Ich zeige euch nämlich mal wie der Upload funktioniert
An der Stelle
Also sprich wenn man auf diesen Upload Button drückt
Dann äh wo ist der Upload Button
Da Upload Button
Dann wird
Ach ne in der Form steht es
In der Form
Genau
Dann wird hier in meinem JavaScript
Die Funktion Upload aufgerufen
Die Upload Funktion sieht man hier
Upload
Oh Gott ist das in Visual Studio kacke
Und dann sieht man was er letztendlich macht
Ähm
Es hält sich sehr in Grenzen
Was hier passiert
Wir führen keine Standardaktion durch
Weil wir wollen selbst Uploaden
Dann nimmt er sich das Form Element
Was man in Vue nicht so macht
Ich weiß aber nicht wie man es in dem Fall anders machen soll
Nimmt alles was in der Form drinnen steht
Also sprich den Text, den Namen, den Hotkey
Plus das Bild
Hängt das an und lädt das hoch
Auf meinen ASP.NET
Webservice
Als Post mit
Mit dem Daten aus dem
Aus dem Formular
So was man jetzt braucht ist
Eigentlich
Weil nach dem Upload geht auch das
Popup nicht zu und sowas
Eigentlich müssen wir jetzt noch die Rückmeldung einbauen
Was schief gelaufen ist
Weil es hat ja gerade einer gesagt
Man kann Alt plus F4 angeben
Könnte ich ja ohne Probleme machen
Ich könnte jetzt sagen als Hotkey möchte ich Alt
Plus F4
Könnte ich machen
Problem ist jetzt das ist ja schon belegt
Das ist ja ein globaler Hotkey von Windows
Spätestens wenn ich hier
Set Hotkey
Wenn ich hier den Hotkey registrieren will
Was aktuell immer nur Hardcode und L macht
Aber da kommt dann auch der richtige Hotkey rein
Hier registriere
Gibt das einen Fehler
Da sagt er mir hallo Achtung Exception
Alt plus F4 ist schon
Error Handling ist komplett
Dann wird er mir hier sagen
Der Hotkey ist schon belegt
Das heißt ich brauche jetzt noch einen Weg zurück
Also sprich
Ich müsste hier irgendwas antworten
Im Falle der Fälle
Wie gesagt Error Handling ist komplett
Overrated
Gehen wir mal in den Controller
Also an der Stelle
Wenn ich auf Upload drücke wird auf Server Seite
Das hier ausgeführt
Ein bisschen weg da nehmen
Das ist alles
Mehr passiert nicht
Also nur diese paar Zeilen
Werden auf Server Seite ausgeführt
Und unter anderem
Guck wie ich die Datei nennen muss
So was ist aber eigentlich relativ egal
Ähm
Hier sagt er dann zum Beispiel
Will Hotkeys setzen
So und jetzt müsste ich anstatt Return OK machen
Hier irgendwie
Return Error im Falle
Von Hotkey ist schon belegt
So sieht es aus
Cool Story Max
Aber das müssen wir machen
Dann würde er beispielsweise hier im Formular anzeigen
Ähm
Wenn ich auf Upload drücke würde er einen Fehler anzeigen
Hotkey ist schon belegt
Und wenn ich auf Web Implementierung
Für Android beziehungsweise iOS um die Memes zu triggern
So könnten die Streamer keinen zweiten PC haben
Ähm
Ja auf jeden Fall
Auf jeden Fall
Bloß wir brauchen dafür gar keine App
Weil du kannst einfach im Browser das Web Interface aufmachen
Das Web Interface
Versuche ich so zu designen
Dass es auch auf Mobile funktioniert
Ein paar Sachen brauchen wir dafür noch
Aktuell werden zum Beispiel
Das Editieren passiert hier mit
Mit mittlerer Maustaste
Das ist absolut nicht Standard
Und checkt eh keiner
Wir werden das dann einfach so machen
Wir machen oben Edit Knopf
Dann geht es in Edit Modus
Man kann die Dinger löschen
Und wir machen es dann einfach so
Ein langer Touch
Weil das kennt man ja von Mobile Sachen
Ein langer Touch auf dieses Ding
Macht das Edit Popup auf
Und dann müssen wir eigentlich nur noch
Für das hinzufügenden Knopf machen
Dass man Zeug hochladen kann
Weil die Bilder und so
Das kann man ja alles vom PC hinzufügen
Und gut ist
Und das Triggern vom Smartphone ist super einfach
Du machst die Seite auf
Und touchst mit dem Knopf hier drauf
Oder touchst mit dem Knopf hier drauf
Äh mit dem
Nicht mit dem Top
Du touchst mit dem Finger
Da drauf oder da drauf
Und dann geht das Bild halt auf
Wenn es läuft
Weil im Hintergrund habe ich es ja ausgemacht gerade
Ich meine
Weil ich meine
Was weiß ich
Fügen wir nochmal irgendwas
Irgendwas hinzu
Das ein bisschen mehr drinnen ist
Man sieht auch wie schön
Fluid das ganze ist
Fluid?
Ne wie heißt es?
Responsive
Stehen da die Webleute drauf
Dass es responsive ist
Guck mal wie krass responsive das ist
Alter ist das responsive
So und das kann man sich einfach
Auf dem Tablet aufmachen
Und dann nimmt man seinen Finger
Und sagt touch
Touch touch
Touch äh
Oh ich habe einen Bug
Er switcht keine Bilder
Ich muss Bilder an und aus machen
Ja aber wie gesagt
Die neue Version ist noch nicht fertig
Deswegen werde ich die auch nicht auf GitHub hochladen
Das sollte zumindest erstmal
Das gleiche
Können
Wie die alte Version
Und dann lade ich es hoch
Brauche ich auch ein paar Tage
Bis das dann ordentlich ist
Genau das macht man sich dann auf dem zweiten Monitor auf
Oder auf einem Tablet auf
Oder auf seinem Smartphone auf
Oder auf seiner Smartwatch
Kann das sowas?
Eher nicht oder?
Kann man auf einer Apple Watch touchen?
Hat eine Apple Watch einen Browser?
Jetzt ernst gemeinte Frage
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Aber Season Pass ist out
Season Pass macht man nicht mehr
Wir machen In-Game Transactions
Äh nicht In-Game wir machen In-App Käufe
Machen wir
Nein nicht wirklich
Ja
Also sprich
Wer das Bild länger als 2 Sekunden anzeigen will
Der muss
Das natürlich erstmal anloggen
Du kannst es anloggen
Entweder
50 Cent PayPal Überweisung
Oder In-Game oder In-App Käufe
Wenn man irgendwelche komischen Challenges erfüllen will
Wie klicke das Bild 20.000 mal an
Und nachdem das keiner machen will
Kauft es sich jeder
So machen wir das
Ne das wird natürlich weiter
Also Scherz bei Seite
Das wird natürlich kostenlos auf Github für alle zur Verfügung stehen
Jeder kann das verwenden was er will
Erstell noch ein Testing Branch
Ja ich erstelle ein Testing Branch
Und auf Github wenn es erstmal ansatzweise läuft
Ja zum Beispiel wenn ich so einen tollen Bug drin habe
Wie das Bild nicht switchen kann
Ist schonmal absolut hängen geblieben
Und außerdem habe ich noch ein paar Comments drin stehen
Sinnlos von mir zusammen gebastelt
Ja
Warum kriege ich eigentlich so viele Follows gerade
Alter was ist denn da los
Danke für die ganzen Follows
Ich gucke gerade mal rein
Aber ich meine gut
Heute sind wir auch nicht einfach einen Programming Stream
Oder einfach einen Creative Stream
Heute sind wir ein Science & Technology Stream
Und da kann dabei eigentlich schonmal gar nichts schief gehen
Ja ich sehe leider nur die letzten paar Follows
Danke für die Follows
Schokoladen Soße
Mirikari Burner
JB
YB nicht JB
Sag mal habt ihr manchmal auch das Problem
Oder ist das einfach nur Brain Lag bei mir
Dass ihr Y und J
Y Y Y Y
Und dass ihr das teilweise im Kopf durcheinander bringt
Das ist
Denke ich lieber mein Gehirn zersetzt sich
Oder so aber manchmal kriege ich es nicht hin
Ja ähm wen haben wir noch am Start
Hallo Gretz
DesertGamer001
Auch da
HK8056
TW
iCoreCS
RadioShark74
Und mehr sehe ich leider nicht
Weil die History nicht reicht
Warum kann man sich
Warum kann man sich nicht die History einfach länger anzeigen lassen
Das ist ganz schön blöd
Ja sorry
Für alle die ich jetzt
Ah ich finde es schön dass ihr da seid
Wie kann man Donaten?
Wenn ihr nicht Donaten möchtet
Kannst du einfach auf die
Channel Info Page
Also da auf die Kanalseite gehen
Da ist ein Paypal Link
Aber wie gesagt muss keiner Donaten sollte eigentlich auch
Im Endeffekt keiner
Wozu ja
Mir reicht es schon wenn euch das Geschwätz
Von mir so weit gefällt
Dass ihr nicht abhaut
Dann ist alles gut ich brauche da keine Kohle für
Ich mache die ganzen Kram ja eh nicht für die Kohle
Geld verdiene ich mit der Arbeit genug
Und dann brauche ich das nicht
Das ist natürlich immer gut
Da sagt natürlich keiner was zu
Wenn ich wirklich Kohle verdienen möchte mit Twitch
Dann werde ich irgendwann mal tatsächlich
Twitch Partner oder sowas
Oder Affiliate oder so in der Richtung
Aktuell mache ich das einfach nur aus Spaß an der Freude
Was auch den großen Vorteil hat
Ich meine ich kann machen was ich will
Wenn ich jetzt quasi
Wenn ich jetzt sehr laut machen müsste
Nachdem ich gestern im Video gesagt habe
Ihr könnt ja mal beim Stream vorbei gucken
Und ich mache ein bisschen Black Ops
Und ich gehe jetzt online
Bei Black Ops ist es natürlich aus Sellout Sicht
Ganz schlecht
Aus Sellout Sicht müsste ich jetzt Black Ops machen
Und nicht irgendwelche komischen
Meme Overlay Dinger programmieren
Das ist ja ne
Fail
Ist euch mal aufgefallen wie schnell das ganze ist
Trotz Datenbank Access im Hintergrund
Aber ich meine in der Datenbank ist auch nichts drin
Warum sollte das langsam sein
Ja
So sieht es aus
Und wir haben jetzt sogar unseren schönen
Japanischen
Was ist denn das da unten
Und auch unseren schönen
Japanischen Text to Speak
Text to Speech
Wie wäre es mit einer neuen Gartentour
Habe ich doch
Erst letztens oder
Habe ich das nicht erst letztens
Moment was ist das
Was ist das
Ergebnis für Max FBS
Geboren 31 Dezember 1984
Moment
Warum
Warum steht öffentlich
Auf Google
Den Geburtstag den ich in meinem Profil
Drinnen stehen habe
Das ist richtig Illuminati
Weil ich bin nicht eingeloggt
Wenn ich eingeloggt wäre würde ich sagen
Ok verstehe ich
Tja
Hast du mal erwähnt in einem Video
Ne habe ich nicht
Weil 31 Dezember ist nämlich sogar falsch
Ähm
Das ist irgendwas was Google selbst
Anbietet
In dem Fall scheißt Google auf meine
Privacy Settings
Weil ich bin mir ziemlich sicher ich habe
Nirgendwo in meinem Profil eingestellt
Dass man davon was sehen darf
Oh guck mal ich habe eine eigene
Youtube Wikia Seite
Was steht denn da
Mal gucken was steht denn da so drauf
Reject ich will keine Cookies
Das ist
Outdated
Ich habe mittlerweile weniger
Weil ich nichts hochgeladen habe
So
Was ist noch verfügbar ins Video
Hat er am 25.10.2010 hochgeladen
Das kann sogar sein
Was ist
Was ist mein ältestes Video
Mein ältestes Video ist
Das erste Video ist es nicht
Da hatte ich Musik drinnen das habe ich gelöscht
Das zweite Video war irgendwas über
Headsets
Das könnte ein Video über Headsets sein
Es ist entweder ein Video über Headsets
Oder
Backyard Code 4 mit Hacker
Eins von beiden
Das ist
Krieg Code 4 auf
Wo ich über Headsets erzähle
Oder es ist Backyard
Mit Hackern
Bam
Alter okay es ist District mit Hackern
Aber
Ich weiß es noch
Hehehe
Ja ist schon ein bisschen her
Warum Code sacken muss
Tja Max warum ist das so
Erzähl es mir
So was steht hier noch so
Dieses wurde leider gelöscht
Erzählt er verschiedenes Themes
Wer erstellt solche Saiten eigentlich
Wer erstellt solche Saiten
Pausenlos
Pausenlos ist gut
Ja Pausenlos
Werden mir alle zustimmen können
Dass ich Pausenlos Videos mache
Pausenlos
Ich mein ich finde das cool
Dass ich da auf irgendeiner YouTube Wiki
Saiten oder einen Eintrag hab
Warum nicht so ist doch nice
News über Terroristen auf der
Playstation, Toiletten am Bahnhof
Ok die Videos haben wahrscheinlich Eintracht gemacht
Ok
Tja
Seine Videos sind immer lustig und informativ
Meisten sind sie doch beides gleichzeitig
Uiuiuiuiuiui
Das ist ja
Wahnsinn was es nicht alles gibt
Ich hoffe das die Videos lustig und informativ
Gleichzeitig sind
So ist das gedacht
Ich cz für scheiß Bilder
oh oh
liste
Leaked.
Face leaked.
Ich habe ein patentiertes Gaming-Klo-Papier.
Was ich manchmal...
Siehste, ich merke mir das überhaupt nicht, wenn ich so einen Mist poste.
Ich wusste überhaupt nicht mehr bis eben, dass ich das überhaupt gepostet habe.
Ja, das bin ich mit dem Kaboom zusammen.
Fällt mir ja gerade so auf.
Nachdem das schon so lange her ist, kann ich euch fragen, was meint ihr, wer ich bin?
Von beiden.
Das hat wohl irgendein Fan geschrieben.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Haha.
Debated.
Ich bin links, nicht rechts.
Der da.
Das ist der Kaboom, das bin ich.
Aber man muss schon mal ehrlich sagen, wir sehen uns da sehr ähnlich auf.
Sowohl vom Haar...
Mittlerweile habe ich hier in den Deuten noch eine ganze Ecke weniger Haare oben drauf.
Wir sehen uns von hinten schon ähnlich irgendwie.
Das ist das Self-Ord gewesen, genau.
Jaja.
Bin ich hier drauf?
Nein.
Bin ich nicht.
Weil es mich irgendwie findet, wenn ich danach suche.
Ich bin nicht im Kindergarten dabei.
Ja, so ist es.
Gut.
Oh Mann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich da jetzt darauf gekommen bin ursprünglich.
Ich wollte irgendwas gucken auf YouTube.
Ich habe es vergessen.
Das wollte ich nicht auf YouTube gucken.
Achso, wie viele Abos ich jetzt habe.
Ja, es ist natürlich ein bisschen weniger mittlerweile.
Gibt ja...
Wenn man keine Videos hochlädt, gibt es auch keine Abos.
Suche am besten auch mal eine Open Source Lizenz raus, damit Porn nicht so problematisch ist.
Ich werde schon keinen verklagen.
Ja, ich weine.
Kann ich machen.
Letztendlich ist es immer gut, wenn man dann eine gewisse Sicherheit hat.
Aber, ich meine, wenn ich im Stream sage, quasi, dass das...
Kann man das im Zweifelsfall ja auch quoten.
Falls ich doch mal irgendeinen verklagen sollte.
Aber warum sollte ich das machen?
Neuestes Video mit Sellout irgendwas.
Ja, genau.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt Black Ops 4 machen, weil ich habe ja gestern ein Video angekündigt.
Was ich übrigens super cool finde irgendwie.
Weil ich mir angucke hier im Video von gestern, ne.
Ähm, ich habe seit einem halben Jahr oder so.
Ja, das zählt nicht.
So diese zwei Dinger.
Also im Prinzip, ich habe dieses Jahr...
Ja doch, ich habe am Anfang des Jahres, habe ich viel hochgeladen.
Aber sagen wir mal so, ich habe ein halbes Jahr mehr oder weniger nichts hochgeladen.
Fast nichts, ja.
Und trotzdem...
Und trotzdem, und das ist halt das, was ich immer irgendwie krass finde.
Und trotzdem, hat das Ding jetzt mittlerweile schon an die 2000 Likes.
Und wahrscheinlich irgendwann, bis es aktualisiert ist, nächstes Mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 20k Views oder so.
200 Comments, vor allem Leute, die sich freuen, dass ich wieder am Start bin.
Und das finde ich halt echt nice, letztendlich, ja.
Ich meine, das ist, dass der Channel war halt einfach komplett tot in ein halbes Jahr.
Und trotzdem sind die Leute noch am Start, das ist halt echt geil.
So Leute müssen natürlich immer noch an den Start kommen.
Diese FPS-Trupps.
Ja, das hat Channelplay versaut.
Also wer sich gewundert hat, warum manche Sachen in dem Video so rumruckeln hier.
So wie zum Beispiel...
Ah, jetzt ruckelt es nicht.
Aber manche Sachen ruckeln.
Ja, das zum Beispiel.
Das war Shadowplay.
Ich weiß nicht, was Shadowplay für Schmerzen hatte.
Wann ist die Pizza fertig?
Die ist schon längst fertig.
Die steht schon hier.
Diese FPS-Trupps.
Ja.
Wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich schon on?
Uptime, 2 Stunden.
2 Stunden, ne?
Leute.
Und außer ein bisschen japanische Text-to-Speech-Geschichte haben wir nichts gemacht.
Nichts.
Ich habe euch die neue Meme-Tool-Version gezeigt, aber sonst nichts.
Da hat er recht.
Free-for-All ist quasi unspielbar.
Ich war ja immer ein großer Free-for-All-Fan.
Und ich würde fast schon sagen, so in den Zeiten, wo ich quasi die Call-of-Duty-Teile, die damals aktuell waren,
also quasi COD 4, 5, Black Ops 1, MW2 und sowas in der Richtung,
da würde ich schon fast sagen, war ich eigentlich fast schon Free-for-All-Spezialist.
Das war der Modus, der mir am besten gefallen hat.
Einfach, weil es dort gefühlt am wenigsten Bullshit gab und es eigentlich nur auf dich ankam.
Das heißt, wenn du schlecht gespielt hast.
Dann hast du meistens es selbst verkackt.
Deswegen habe ich Free-for-All gerne gespielt.
Auch in den alten Call-of-Duties.
Allerdings muss ich echt, muss ich sagen, in Black Ops 4 ist Free-for-All, finde ich, wirklich...
Da muss ich ihm recht geben hier.
Den Namen auszusprechen ist nicht politisch korrekt.
Heutzutage werde ich bestimmt gebannt.
Tryhard 7.
Ja, und das ist wirklich fast unspielbar.
Das ist so schlimm, weil Black Ops 4 hat in Free-for-All schon noch so die typischen Call-of-Duty-Spiele.
Die Call-of-Duty-Revenge-Spawn.
Also ihr kennt das ja wahrscheinlich noch.
So nach dem Motto, du killst einen und du kannst dir zu 99% sicher sein, der Typ spawnt jetzt hinter der nächsten Ecke hinter dir.
Sonst kannst du eigentlich schon fast umdrehen.
Und das heißt, du hast öfters dann auch mal durch diese 150 HP, dass du quasi...
Dass es übelst Chaos ist.
Dass du einen killst und schon der nächste wieder am Start ist.
Der nächste respawn schon wieder.
Der andere ist nicht richtig tot.
Es ist scheiße zu spielen.
Muss man ehrlich sagen.
Also Free-for-All gefällt mir überhaupt gar nicht.
Soviel da.
Dazu.
Muss ich jetzt einfach mal loswerden.
Ist dein Deutsch schlechter geworden?
Weiß ich nicht.
Es gibt Jugendsprache, es gibt Umgangssprache, es gibt die Assi-Sprache, es gibt die Max-Sprache.
Ja, es haben sich ja schon so manche Sachen etabliert.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob der Friseur am Start ist.
Weil eigentlich wollten wir nachher noch eine Runde im Discord was besprechen.
Nicht, dass ich das jetzt verpasse oder so.
Nee.
Ist es nicht unmöglich, drei Leute auf einmal zu killen?
Also wenn man sich das Video anguckt, ist es nicht unmöglich.
Da kill ich manchmal drei Leute auf einmal.
Oder mehr oder weniger auf einmal.
Allerdings.
Es ist fast unmöglich.
Also es ist frontal unmöglich.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher, wie gut die...
Diese Bullet Penetration noch ist.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die Schüsse gehen nur noch ziemlich schlecht durch Gegner durch.
Oder durch Teammates durch.
Weiß nicht, ob das ein Unterschied ist zu den alten Cods.
Also zu den älteren, weil die letzten paar hab ich ja nicht gespielt, wirklich.
Gefühlt schon.
Das Problem ist, drei Gegner kriegst du kaum down.
Frontal auf gar keinen Fall.
Und, also selbst wenn sie perfekt laufen.
Also auch irgendwie so diese Sniper-360-Collateral-Geschichten.
Naja.
Und du kriegst die Gegner, du kriegst drei Gegner auch von hinten nicht richtig down.
Weil...
So einen Turn...
Mit der Maus zu machen, kriegt jeder halbwegs schnell hin.
Und...
Mit dem Controller ist es vielleicht auch ein bisschen schwieriger.
Aber gut geflankt war in älteren Call of Duties, vor allem in Team Deathmatch,
wenn man jetzt halt nicht diese Streak-Geschichte machen wollte.
Oder Teammates, die supportet haben.
Wenn man quasi Solo-Team-Deathmatch-Gespieler wollte, ordentlich was reißen.
Da hast du es ja oftmals für einen guten Start und für die...
Quasi, dass man Killstreaks vor den anderen kriegt,
muss man dann gute Flank-Aktionen machen.
Und das kannst du in Black Ops 4 komplett vergessen.
Kannst du knicken.
Du flankst, killst eins, zwei und der dritte dreht sich halt in der Zwischenzeit um und killt dich.
Das kannst du knicken.
Und ja, das ist auch noch so eine Sache.
Längere Kämpfe sind schwierig,
weil sobald man sich aus den Augen verliert,
kann man sich eigentlich sicher sein,
ich drück mir jetzt eine Spritze rein
und der Gegner drückt sich jetzt auch ein Stimpack rein.
Und ist wieder auf 100%.
Dafür kann man...
Und das finde ich eigentlich in Black Ops 4 ganz schön.
Dafür kann man ein halbwegs gutes Anti-Bullshit-Perk-Setup machen.
Man kann sich nämlich als...
Ins erste Perk-Slot kann man sich reinpacken
Tactical Mask und Flag Jacket.
Wenn man die Perk hat, dass man zwei Stück verwenden kann.
Dann nimmt man noch irgendwie sowas wie Light White und Ghost oder sowas.
Und dann ist man...
...vor relativ viel Bullshit.
Bullshit eigentlich sicher.
Eigentlich, ja.
Es gibt genug anderen Bullshit,
aber man kann sich, finde ich,
ein ganz gutes Anti-Bullshit-Perk-Setup zusammenbasteln.
Plus, dann kann man noch den Operator nehmen,
den man am liebsten hat,
indem man ihm quasi dann noch ein zusätzliches Gadget in die Hand drückt.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen,
wenn ich den Operator mit dem Hund am liebsten spiele
oder den Operator mit dem One-Shot-Revolver...
Ach, Ghost funktioniert nicht?
Tja.
Es ist eh ziemlich viel kaputt in dem Game.
Und dann kann ich dann quasi sagen,
okay, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie, wie heißt die, Seraph oder so spiele mit dem One-Shot-Revolver,
allerdings finde ich zum Beispiel das Spawn-Peaken doof,
weil das...
Naja, Team Deathmatch heißt zwar Team,
aber in Call of Duty spielt keiner Team Deathmatch als Team.
Das heißt, dann kann ich das Spawn-Peaken für den Punkt auswechseln zu einer Frag oder sowas.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool.
Ich finde das Perk-System gar nicht schlecht diesmal.
Das Game hat sau viele Bugs.
Wenn man mal auf Reddit guckt,
da hast du hier einen, der sich drüber aufregt,
dass...
dass man permanent 200 HP hat beim Spawn,
dass, ähm...
Emote-Klitsch...
Kennt ihr den Emote-Klitsch?
Den Blackout-Emote-Klitsch?
Auch sehr beliebt.
Ähm...
Dass irgendwie...
Genau, dass 200 HP spawnen,
dass, ähm...
Nein, Bang...
Nein, nicht Nein, Kack.
Nein, Bang.
Übelst OP ist.
Aber es sind einige Sachen auch wirklich einfach broken.
Emote-Klitsch.
Ja.
Ganz einfach.
Blackout ist Ego-Perspektive, also Battle-Royale-Ego-Perspektive.
Und du kannst Emotes auswählen.
Die Emotes funktionieren wie in Overwatch.
Also sprich, du hast...
Du sagst dann, ich will jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, äh...
Hinsatz-Emote machen.
Und dann geht die Kamera von Ego-Perspektive auf Third-Party...
auf Third-Person-View.
Und du siehst mehr.
Also sprich, du kannst dich zum Beispiel...
Du machst einen Sitz-Emote.
Auf einem Dach.
Und dich sieht keiner mehr, weil du auf dem Dach sitzt.
Du selbst kannst aber rumgucken.
Third-Person, alles was um das Haus drumherum ist.
Das ist übelst unfair in Blackout.
Und warum da keiner beim Testen draufgekommen ist,
ist mir vollkommen schleierhaft.
Ja.
Vollkommen.
Also, da hast du fast das Gefühl, das Game hat mal wieder keiner getestet.
Shrek-Spawn in Black Ops 4.
Das finde ich sogar ganz cool irgendwie.
Ja.
Äh, die Rüstungen in Blackout sind...
auch extrem gut.
Footsteps-Sounds sind mega broken, da hat er recht.
Footsteps, ähm, hörst du manchmal drei Kilometer weit.
Manchmal gar nicht.
Manchmal kannst du nicht zuordnen, wo sie herkommen.
Wenn man Duo spielt.
Ich habe ja vorhin ein paar Runden mit dem Eax Duo gespielt, Blackout.
Footsteps kommen aus zwei verschiedenen Richtungen teilweise.
Also sprich, wir sind gelandet auf Array der Eax auf dem Dach.
Ich bin unten in das Haus rein.
Und der ist über mir auf dem Dach gelaufen.
Und dadurch hat sich...
hat sich das so angehört, als kommen quasi Gegner von der anderen Seite.
Das war ganz, ganz weird.
Also, Fuß, äh, also, ne, Fußschritte sind komplett kaputt in dem Game.
Was auch komisch ist, dass man diese Effekt-Sounds nicht ausschalten kann.
Also diese, diese Medals, die man kriegt in-Game.
Da kann man den Sound nicht für ausschalten.
Genau.
Spawning in, in a Scratch, äh, mit 200 Hells.
Das ist auch ein schöner Wack.
Äh, SMGs sollten tatsächlich gebufft werden, sehe ich auch.
Bis auf eine ist die, sind die eigentlich ziemlich kacke.
Tja.
TDM endet tatsächlich ein bisschen, ein bisschen früh, finde ich auch.
Aber, da zeigt ihr seine Cod-Sammlung.
Da kann ich nicht mithalten.
Ich hab Cod 2.
Cod 1 hab ich gar nicht mehr.
Cod 2 hab ich auf dem PC.
Cod 3 hatte ich nie.
4 hab ich auf dem PC, auf der PS3 und auf der 360.
World at War hab ich auf der 360.
MW2 hab ich auf der 360.
Black Ops 360.
Ähm, 3, MW3 hab ich, 3, auf der 360, Black Ops 2 und Ghosts auch, wobei, nie richtig gespielt.
Advanced Warfare hab ich auf dem PC und auf der, kam das schon auf der Xbox One?
War, war das Xbox One schon, Advanced Warfare?
Oder war das auf 360?
Dann hab ich nämlich auf der Xbox One, das war das Spiel, wo ich festgestellt hab, dass mir der Xbox One Controller schlechter geht.
Schlechter gefällt als der 360 Controller.
Ähm, und PC?
Black Ops 3 hab ich nicht.
Infinite Warfare hab ich auch nicht.
Doch, hab ich, hab, nee, hab ich nicht.
Infinite Warfare hab ich nicht.
Advanced Warfare war das mit Kevin Spacey, oder?
Infinite Warfare, weiß ich gar nicht, um was es da ging.
Ja, World War 2 hab ich auf dem PC, wobei, ja gut, World War...
Nee.
Moment.
Die Beta hab ich gespielt.
Doch, hab ich auch auf dem PC.
Und das, naja, also.
Ich hab tatsächlich mehr Kotz, als ich's, als ich's haben will.
Tja.
Gut, Leute, ich mach jetzt mal kurz aus, nö.
Und, äh, esse jetzt ein bisschen Pizza.
Wie heißt die Musik, die gerade im Hintergrund läuft?
Ähm.
Chillstep 24-7 Livestream.
Chill Ambient Study Musik.
Hier.
Ascelia...
Thing.
Übrigens.
Hab ich euch schon das Beste...
Das kann ich euch mal kurz zeigen.
Play Gobs.
Ähm.
Hab ich euch schon das Beste gezeigt?
Ich kann das nicht spielen mit dem Account.
Ich hab das auf einem anderen Account.
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich das mit dem falschen Account starte?
Ich hab das Game mit dem Account nicht.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was jetzt passiert.
Wahrscheinlich kackt's ab, oder so.
Ach so.
Ja.
Aber, aber es kann sich nicht direkt...
Ja gut, dann kann ich euch das nachzeigen.
Der Theater-Modus ist richtig cool diesmal.
Ist das etwa wie Game-Sharing, ja?
Das wär geil, wenn das funktioniert.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was auch komplett kaputt ist?
Ähm.
Ich wollte dem Eax das Game giften über Battle.net.
Und das hat, glaube ich, drei Stunden oder so gedauert.
Ich meine, das ist ein Online-Shop.
Das ist...
Warum dauert das drei Stunden, ein Game zu giften?
Das klickst du an, der setzt einen Flag bei dem irgendwie...
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh.
In der Datenbank für den User beim Eax, das auf True Owns Black Ops 4 oder so.
Und dann ist es da.
Warum dauert das drei Stunden?
Äh, what?
Ich meine...
Sogar mein komisches Webinterface, was gerade kaputt ist, geht schneller.
50 Euro Code bis heute nicht bekommen.
Ja, ich weiß auch nicht, was die da machen.
Ich meine, auf Steam geht's doch auch.
Und ich meine, auf Steam ist mehr los, deutlich mehr los, als auf Battle.net.
Also Shop-mäßig, ja?
Wahrscheinlich sitzt da der Inder irgendwo.
Und muss jedes Gift einzeln noch irgendwie bestätigen und eintippen oder so.
Oh, ich muss was essen.
My name is Peter.
Ich habe letztens so ein Scam-Video geguckt.
Wo wieder irgend so ein indischer Microsoft-Support angerufen hat, ja?
Also, den sie halt verarscht haben.
Die haben halt dort angerufen und haben gesagt, ja, hier, mein Windows hat Fehler.
Und guckt euch das mal an.
Ihr kennt ja, weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, diese indischen Support.
In indischen Microsoft-Fake-Support-Verarschungsvideos.
Und da ging dann halt ein Inder dran.
Und hat sich nicht etwa gemeldet, halt mit einem indischen Namen.
Sondern meinte dann so irgendwie, weil er hat halt gesagt, der Typ, ich rufe auf Deutschland an.
Und da geht dann der Inder dran von Microsoft-Support und meint so, mein Name ist Peter.
Und ich denke so, was?
Klingt sehr glaubwürdig.
Du rufst eine indische Nummer an, der Typ hört sich sowas von indisch an.
Ja?
Spricht das schlechteste Deutsch aller Zeiten und will dir erzählen, er heißt Peter.
Ist klar, ja?
Ganz bestimmt.
Bitte anlassen.
Was, beim Pizza-Essen?
Wollen wir den ASMR-Eating-Sounds-Pizza-Stream machen, oder was?
Aber die Videos gucke ich mir gerne an, diese Microsoft-Scam-Videos.
Also nicht Microsoft-Scam, sondern Fake-Microsoft-Support-Leute, die gescampt werden.
Was passiert, wenn man auf Spam antwortet?
Den Vortrag kenne ich.
Wobei ich mir da nicht sicher bin, wie gefaket da manche Sachen sind.
Das ist das, worauf irgendwie so eine Nigeria-Spam-E-Mail, sie haben was geerbt, antwortet, ne?
Richtiger deutscher Support meldet sich nicht mit Vornamen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die legen gleich wieder auf.
Wenn du irgendwie bei Unity Media oder so anrufst, die haben schon keinen Bock mehr.
Dann solltest du die Kita-Burger anschauen.
Ja, ich habe ein paar so Channels.
Kann durchaus sein, dass ich von ihnen sogar schon was geguckt habe.
Ja.
Wie viele Follows heute?
Alter, was ist da los?
Danke für die ganzen Follows.
Ich gucke nochmal rein.
Wer ist jetzt hier neu dabei gekommen?
Der Mosel1337.
Good Guy Michi ist am Start.
The Cry Nat.
Little D2608.
Schnitzelwutz.
Also manche Namen sind tatsächlich kreativ irgendwie.
LOL0711.
The Fabulous Muffin.
Last Defender XY.
Aber mehr sehe ich nicht.
Kommen alle vom YouTube-Video.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich, denke ich auch.
So, ähm, also ich werde jetzt meine Pizza futtern und danach spielen wir, ich sage jetzt nicht hundertprozentig, weil ihr wisst, was passiert, wenn ich sage, ich mache das, dann mache ich es nicht, also so wie Videos, so nach dem Motto, bis zum nächsten Mal und dann gibt es demnächst noch und dann mache ich das nicht.
Deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht, dass es danach hundertprozentig noch einen Black Ops 4 Stream gibt, aber ich sage mal, ich habe noch nichts anderes vor, als einen Black Ops 4 Stream zu machen.
Nachdem ich meine Pizza gefuttert habe.
Und ich lasse den Stream nicht an beim Pizza futtern, weil dann muss ich mich so zurückhalten beim Pizza essen.
Da muss man dann immer so gesittet sein, das geht nicht, weil sonst hört sich das so eklig an für die Leute.
Das, ich muss, die Pizza muss reingestopft werden.
Hits.
Heute Mittag gab es Sushi, Abend gibt es Pizza, also sprich, heute Mittag gab es was Gesundes, heute Abend gibt es dann halt was auch sehr Gesundes.
Immersive Pizza, ja, das ist Immersive Audio.
3D.
Immersive Audio, Immersive Pizza Eating.
Okay, Leute.
War schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nachher nochmal mit Black Ops 4.
Bis gleich, ich gehe jetzt meine Pizza futtern.
Bis dann.
See you.